[Musique]
bonsoir ou rebonsoir merci en tout cas
d'avoir choisi France 3 pour vivre cette
passionnante soirée de l'élection
présidential du prier Tour 2007 dans 30
minutes vous verrez apparaître
évidemment les noms des deux candidats
qui seront qualifiés pour le second tour
une estimation que nous fournirons nos
partenaires CSA et Cisco pour l'instant
même si nous avons quelques indications
nous ne pouvons rien vous dire c'est
frustrant mais c'est la loi le chiffre
en revanche que nous pouvons vous
communiquer c'est celui du taux de
participation du taux de participation
du taux de l'estimation de l'abstention
pardon elle est selon CSA Cisco de 15,7
15,7 c'est le taux de l'abstention
voilà il y a 5 ans Louis le 21 avril
2002 pour le premer tour de l'élection
présidentielle l'abstention était
beaucoup plus élevé puisque le taux
d'abstention était de
28,4 % en
1995 toujours au premier tour le taux
d'abstention était de 21,6 % en fait il
faut remonter à 1965 la première
élection présidentielle au suffrage
universel pour trouver un taux
d'abstention aussi bas que celui que
nous prévoit à l'institut CSA avec Cisco
15,7 % je le rappelle en ce qui concerne
le chiffre de la participation hein
cette fois-ci chiffre officiel ce n'est
plus une estimation nous allons
retrouver en direct du ministère de
l'Intérieur Dominique martinau qui va
nous donner le le chiffre de
participation à 17h oui Louis ben c'est
74 % de participation à 17h et c'est
énorme et 2007 pourrait donc bien
pulvériser le score record de l'élection
présidentielle de 1965 où ils étaient 84
% de votants en tout cas c'est que c'est
sûr ce chiffre de ce taux de
participation dépasse celui à la même
heure de 2002 de 10 points et euh de 15
points pardon et de 1995 de 10 points
alors l'une des raisons bien sûr vous
savez c'est la formidable hausse des
inscriptions sur les listes électorales
plus 3 plus de 3300000 nouveaux
électeurs du jamais vu depuis 25 ans
cela s'explique d'abord par la
croissance démographique car beaucoup de
de jeunes de 18 ans ne pouvaient pas
voter en 2002 mais aussi peut-être aussi
par un certain engouement politique un
nouvel engouement politique puisqu'on a
vu se multiplier des inscriptions dans
des inscriptions sur les listes
électorales dans les villes et dans les
banlieux après les émeutes de 2005 merci
Dominique martinau alors cette élection
est évidemment très intéressante avec
cette année des des candidats nouvelle
génération des électeurs très motivés
même s'ils sont indécis Roland kérol
vous dirigez l'institut CSA vous êtes
associé pour cette opération avec Cisco
vous estimez donc le taux d'abstention à
15,7 c'est très faible c'est quasiment
historique oui ça ça flirte avec les les
records parce que c'est 15,7 en
métropole qu' faut donc comparer à 15,2
en 1965 la toute première élection
présidentielle 15,8 en 74 vous vous
rendez compte il faut 30 ans en arrière
on avait l'habitude à chaque soirée
électorale de dire c'est un record de
baisse de l'abstention par rapport à
toutes les élections du même genre
depuis 30 ans on disait ça c'est la
première fois qu'on va pouvoir dire il y
a un redressement sur par - qu'on peut
en dire al c'est très embêtant parce que
on pourrait en dire beaucoup de choses
tout de suite maisfin attendons 20h ce
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'en général
quand il y a plus de participation c'est
pas bon pour les extrêmes les les les
les gens qui votent aux extrêmes ils
sont très motivés alors qu'il est ou pas
un fort tau de mobilisation eux ils y
vont quand tout le monde y va ça veut
dire que les modérés ceux qui
s'intéressent de moins direct moins
directement à la politique ils vont
aussi c'est plutôt favorable au grand
parti de gouvernement merci alors on se
retrouve évidemment dans dans quelques
minutes euh mais nous allons aussi tout
au long de la soirée retrouver nos nos
envoyés spéciaux qui sont dans les QG
des des candidats euh ou maintenant dans
une vingtaine de minutes hein ce seront
des des cris de de joie ou des cris de
de de dépis et des larmes euh Audra nous
allons présenter le le dispositif de
cette soirée élection présidentielle
2007 avec beaucoup de de nouveautés euh
techniqu et et technologiqu bien sûr
nous attendons à France 3 de nos
téléspectateurs qu'ils participent à
leur façon à cette soirée électorale en
envoyez-nous vos vidéos vos photos
prises depuis vos téléphones portables à
l'adresse et email qui va s'afficher
voilà vous pouvez les envoyer à
videoéo@france3.fr ou au 06 30
290807 postez-nous également vos films
réalisés depuis vos webcam ou des
caméras DV directement vers le site
france3.fr et vous le voyez il y a toute
une équipe qui est prête pour recevoir
ses contributions faites-nous vivre la
façon dont vous percevez cette soirée
électorale alors une soirée que vous
pouvez également suivre sur
france3.fr avec notamment un point
complet tous les quarts d'heure avec
Xavier roman la plupart des des bureaux
de vote ont fermé à 18h mais certains et
dans les grande ville bien sûr ne ferme
qu'à qu'à 20h c'est donc le
dépouillement dans certains bureaux de
vote dans d'autres bureaux de vote on se
presse encore pour pour voter nous
allons aller dans le 14e arrondissement
de de Paris où se trouve Amélie desois
est-ce que vous vous avez des des
retardateurs des votants de dernières
minutes apparemment ils sont derrière
vous écoutez il y reste quelques
retardateurs en effet mais finalement
dans ce bureau de vote l'affluence a été
continue tout au long de la journée nous
sommes dans le plus important bureau de
vote du 14e arrondissement et ici il a
fallu se réorganisé pour faire face à
l'affluence donc on a augmenté le nombre
de files au plus fort de la journée la
file d'attente s'est même étendue
jusqu'à l'extérieur sur le trottoir
alors certains ont même dû attendre
jusqu'à 40 minutes pour pouvoir déposer
leur bulletin dans l'urne et la
participation et bien les records à
l'image de la France à 19h30 elle était
de 83 % dans ce bureau de vote donc là
ils n'ont plus que quelques instants un
gros quart d'heure pour voter à 20h on
ferme le bureau de vote ceux qui sont
présents dans la salle évidemment eux
pourront voter merci améliee Simp
j'ajoute simplement pardon que qu'un
dépêche vient de tomber indiquant qu' il
sera possible pour les électeurs de
voter après l'heure de clôture de 20h
dans les dans les grandes villes pour
ceux qui sont encore présents dans la et
cette soirée vous allez donc pouvoir la
suivre chez vous bien sûr seul en
famille ou entre amis mais vous allez
pouvoir la suivre aussi à travers les
les ambiances dans les quartiers
généraux des des candidats où sont
rassemblés les militants nous allons
tout de suite prendre la direction de
l'UMP non pas la la rue d'anguin dans le
10e qui a pourtant servi de de siège de
campagne à Nicolas Sarkozi mais à la
salgavo donc dans le 8e juste à côté du
du siège de l'UMP quelle est l'ambiance
Patrice machouré bah écoutez là la salle
gavo s'est remplie hein les sièges ont
été enlevés en contrebat pour pouvoir
accueillir je vous le disais tout à
l'heure les 3000 militants alors
évidemment depuis 1 heure des bruits des
rumeurs des chiffres cercule donc bon
voilà on attend ici le staff les élus
les personnes présentes attendent bien
sûr la communication officielle des
résultats mais tout le monde rappelle
que Nicolas Sarkozi a quand même été
donné favori depuis le début de la
campagne des dizaines et dizaines de
sondages l'ont donné aux têtees au
premier tour non il se pose une question
apparemment plus politique c'est-à-dire
finalement va-t-il faire mieux sur son
nom que Jacques Chirac record était en
95 au prier tour Jacques Chirac avait
fait 20,84 % des voix donc ça c'est une
première chose une autre chose c'est
bien sûr le score de Segolen royale et
de François beou qui peut fournir un bon
report de voie au second tour donc ça
c'est la deuxième grande interrogation
des gens présents ici et bien sûr la
troisème chose c'est le score de
Jean-Marie Le Pen on verra tout à
l'heure merci et justement le score de
Jean-Marie Le Pen nous allons prendre la
direction du Front national qui comme
l'UMP a déménagé pour pour cette soirée
le FN qui est donc rassemblé dans le 15e
l'équinoxe éc tibaau on a vu les choses
en grand au Front national ce soir et
ben oui on a vu en grand mais en fait
ici il n'y a personne en fait il n'y a
pas de militants on voit simplement 500
journalistes et techniciens qui sont
agrédités Jean-Marie Le Pen lui est
toujours au siège du Front national à
saint-clou et en fait on l'attend ici
d'un moment à l'autre mais il n'y a pas
non plus de leader du Front national en
fait aucun militant n'est encore arrivé
alors qu'on en attendait 1500 alors je
vous rappelle l'enjeu Jean-Marie Le Pen
a dit qu'il se qualifierait pour le 2ème
tour donc on verra bien en tout cas le
vrai enjeu pour Jean-Marie Le Pen c'est
de faire aussi bien en voie qu'en 2002
c'est je vous le rappelle il avait
recueilli alors 4800000 voix merci Eric
on se retrouve tout à l'heure nous
allons maintenant en poitoucharante à
Mel le fief électoral de seégolen royale
Marie-Pierre courtellement la la
candidate socialiste est-elle toujours
parmi ses concitoyens
elle est parmi ses concitoyens pour le
moment enfermé dans sa maison depuis
l'heure de 14h elle est avec Juli
viendrait en compagnie également de
David Assouline et de Vincent payon la
candidate qui a voté peu avant 12h30 il
faut savoir que il y a beaucoup
d'effervescence ici à Mel aujourd'hui
cette petite bourgade du Sud des Deux
Sèvres de 5000 habitants a vu
littéralement débouler entre 200 et 300
journalistes il y a ici des Japonais des
Coréens qui sont venus photographier
filmer la candidate qui a ensuite fait
visiter la ville de mêle elle leur a
fait faire le tour de la ville de ses
églises romanes avant donc de
rentrer chez elle et elle fera une
déclaration assez courte ce soir aux
alentours de 20h30 ici depuis Mel avant
de rentrer sur Paris merci Marie-Pierre
nous allons maintenant prendre la
direction de l'UDF au QG de campagne de
François beou Daniel Sportiello quelle
est
l'ambiance alors nous avons un petit
problème de liaison sonore avec Daniel
Sportiello on vous retrouve tout à
l'heure Daniel nous allons aller
retrouver Clément veyenal qui ce soir
pour nous va nous faire vivre un petit
peu respirer l'atmosphère de de la
capitale je vous vois Clément où
êtes-vous si où l'ambiance est
parfaitement calme et bon enfant et où
nous avons voulu vérifier ou non une
hypothèse selon laquelle à l'heure
d'Internet et des textos l'information
circulerait plus vite et parviendrait à
tout un chacun avant l'annonce des
résultats officiels et bien non et bien
non vous savez regardez par exemple
derrière moi la plupart des gens qui se
trouvent aux terrasses de de café que
nous avons interrogé ne connaissent pas
les résultats n'ont pas cherché à les
connaître ne veulent même pas les
connaître aucune rumeur vraie ou fausse
ne leur est parvenu ils nous ont
simplement dit qu'ils préféraent
profiter des derniers rayons du soleil
avant de rentrer chez eux pour suivre la
soirée officielle devant leur poste de
télévision voilà et peut-être par contre
que l'ambiance changera dans le quartier
après l'annonce des rés résultats et
nous nous retrouverons tout au long de
la soirée bon merci Clément profitez
aussi vous des derniers rayons de soleil
la moto le quad qui sert d'émetteur ce
sont des des nouveautés techniques que
nous testons ce soir mais ce ne sont pas
les seules oui je vous le disais tout à
l'heure vous pouvez intervenir dans
cette émission en nous envoyant vos
photos vos films réalisés depuis vos
téléphones portables à l'adresse et au
numéro de téléphone qui vont s'inscrire
immédiatement vous pouvez les envoyer au
06 30
290807 ou à
videoéo@fance3.fr et puis vous pouvez
également nous poster directement sur
France 3 vos films réalisés à partir de
à partir de webcam ou de DVS où que vous
vous trouviez dans le monde y compris
cela est valable pour les 800000
Français qui votent à l'étranger merci
Audrey il est
19h41 nous allons nous retrouver dans
une poignée de 2 minutes pour vivre
ensemble le compte à rebour jusqu'à 20h
mais tout de suite c'est Catherine
matoche pour les autres faits marquants
de l'actualité de ce dimanche 22 avril
bonsoir et si vous le voulez bien
restons sur sur l'ambiance de ce premier
tour dès 8h ce matin il y avait du monde
dans les bureaux de vote dans les heures
qui ont suivi beaucoup beaucoup
d'électeurs ont dû faire preuve de
patience certains bureaux en effet se
sont retrouvés débordés par l'affu des
nouveaux électeurs d'autres embarrassés
par le vote électronique toutefois ce
que l'on retiendra d'abord de ce premier
tour du scrutin c'est l'exceptionnelle
mobilisation des électeur Lorian de
casanov
gyandols on avait pas vu pareil fil
d'attente de devant les bureaux de vote
depuis l'avènement de la 5e République
un taux de participation record les
habitués n'en reviennent pas ce qui me
surprend c'est que je vote ici depuis 81
je n'ai jamais vu une telle file
d'attente on se croirait au cinéma
j'espère qu'ils vont pas nous faire per
ça fait la deuxième fois que je viens
puisque je suis venue vers 13h 13h30
c'était pareil donc j'avais pas déjeuné
ben je suis je suis revenue voilà on m'a
dit qu'il y avait à peu près une
demi-heure d'attente les bureaux de vote
sont débordés en raison du nombre de
nouveaux inscrits sur les listes
électorales parmi eux beaucoup de jeunes
allez-y
mademoiselle à voter comme ici à clich
sousbois en banlieu
parisienne ce qui m'a motivé à aller
voter bah c'est que déjà tout le
monde plein de jeunes de la cité qui
vont voter tout ça on a à peu près le
même avis tout ça seul bé vote
électronique 1 million et demi
d'électeurs sont concernés et cela n'a
pas toujours été simple dans ce bureau
de reince une seule machine fonctionn
enfin presque parce que apparemment on a
des problèmes de carte j'ai bien mis la
carte correctement puis aprèson j'ai
attendis mais j'ai pas eu comment la fin
il y a un ticket qui doit sortir et oui
monsieur il vous faut un reçu malgré
tout ces aléas les bureaux de vote ne
désemplissent pas c'est le cas à Amien
la première fois que je vote pour un
président donc j'ai envie de m'investir
dedans faut voter ça il y a pas il y a
au qu'une excuse pour n pas aller voter
voilà le son de séduction en iser
décidément cette année tout aura été
fait pour convaincre les citoyens
d'aller voter cette station proposé aux
électeurs ayant accompli leurs devoirs
un forfait au prix défiant toute
concurrence de 1 €. et on vous l' déjà
dit en raison de l'afflu des électeurs
il sera possible de de voter après la
fermeture des bureaux annonces faite ce
soir par le Conseil constittu in dans
l'actualité aussi près de Grenoble une
petite fille âgée de 2 ans a disparu une
centaine de personnes la recherchent
depuis cet après-midi l'enfant qui
jouait dans le jardin
clos de sa famille situé près d'une
rivière a ouvert un petit portillon
aussitôt l'alerte donné des plongeurs
des équipes cinophiles des policiers des
bénévoles se sont rendus sur place tous
ratissent les berges de l'iser très
boisé à cet endroit et puis un nouveau
cimetière en France a été profané cette
fois-ci au Havre euh 180 tombes dont un
quart de confessions juives ont été
profanés la nuit dernière dans le
cimetière saintte-marie du Havre l'un
des principaux 5q jeunes dont deux
mineurs de presque 18 ans ont été
interpellés par la police sur les lieux
dans la nuit euh ils sont ce soir
toujours en garde- à vue les tombes ont
été très fortement dégradées a déclaré
le le procureur euh condamnation avec
une extrême fermeté du président de la
République qui a dénoncé je le cite une
insulte à la mémoire de nos morts et une
blessure pour tous les Français près
d'ara l'enquête est allée très vite
trois jeunes dont un mineur ont avoué
avoir profané les 52 tombes musulmanes
du cimetière militaire Notre-Dame de
Laurette leur motivation raciste Laurent
navez Richard
Ogier la profanation semble avoir été
bien préparée selon leurs déclaration
les trois auteurs présumés avaient
repéré les lieux c'était réparti les
tâches pour souiller les 50 de stelles
et porter des cagoules c'est grâce au
témoignage d'un promeneur et à la
peinture retrouvée à leur domicile
qu'ils ont été confondus de majeurs de
22 ans un mineur de 16 ans des jeunes
désœuvrés habitant des communes voisines
du cimetière militaire leur motivation
des actes racistes guidés par une
idéologie skinaet des néonazis qu'on a
retrouvé par exemple dans la
perquisition chez l'un des présumés
auteurs une bague une bague avec un des
cles un sigle nazi on a retrouvé aussi
des discours d'clair dans les
déclarations qui ont été prises par la
gendarmerie l' auteurs dit que Hitler a
vaincu le chômage et que c'est son idole
les trois individus ont été déférés au
parquet ce matin et placés sous mandat
de dépôt un juge des enfants décidera du
sort de l'adolescent les deux adultes
seront jugés mercredi prochain à haras
en comparution immédiate je présenterai
mercredi au tribunal des réquisitions
d'une grande fermeté voulant ainsi
rendre hommage à ces soldats de la
Grande Guerre de confession musulmane
mort pour la France pour dégradation
grave commise en réunion avec un motif
raciste ou religieux les auteurs
présumai en cours 5 ans d'emprisonnement
et 75000 € d'amende sur la colline de
Notre-Dame de Laurette les stelles ont
été nettoyées dès vendredi le cimetière
militaire a retrouvé sa quiétude enc sa
ajaction hier soir une manifestation
nationaliste est terminée par des heures
entre quelques jeunes et les forces de
l'ordre et puis le jour du premier tour
de la présidentielle trois attentats ont
été commis un cap- Corse un relais
France-Télécom a été légèrement
endommagé deux autres bombes ont explosé
à Bastia faisant un blessé Pierre
Nicolas d'ordinaire les dizaines
d'attentats perpétrés ces dernières
années par les nationalistes corses ne
faisaient pas de victime ni morts ni
blessés c'est même une spécificité de ce
mouvement par rapport à d'autres groupes
séparatistes en Europe mais la nuit
dernière la machine s'est emballée la
déflagration qui a dévasté la façade
d'une agence du Trésor public de Bastia
était si puissante qu'elle a projeté une
grille sur sur un passant blessé au
visage et aux mains le jeune homme de 22
ans a été hospitalisé ses jours ne sont
pas en danger deux autres attentats l'un
contre la direction départementale des
affaires maritimes sur le vieux port de
Bastia l'autre contre un relais de
France Télécom dans le Cap Corse
viennent s'ajouter aux actions de la
veille notamment le mitraillage d'une
gendarmerie à corau en Corse du Sud ce
regain de tension intervient alors que
les Français votent pour le prochain
Président de la République plusieurs
candidats sont pourtant passés sur lî
ces dernières semaines chacun y allant
de sa petite promesse mais la Corse
n'était pas cette année au cœur des
débats comme elle l'était lors des
précédents scrutin présidentiel certains
indépendantistes ont semble-t-il décidé
de rappeler bruyamment dans la dernière
ligne droite la pérennité de leurs
revendication le ministre de l'Intérieur
françois Barouin a condamné ce matin
avec la plus grande fermeté cette
nouvelle série d'attentats image de
découement voilà ce que l'on peut
retenir de de l'actualité Louis à à 10
minutes maintenant he des premières
estimations merci Catherine
effectivement nous sommes maintenant à
quelques minutes de l'heure fatidique il
est
19h49 dans 11 minutes vous nous pourrons
donc vous donner les premières
estimations des scores des deux
candidats et évidemment des scores des
deux premiers pour l'instant un chiffre
c'est celui de l'abstention de
l'estimation de l'abstention fournie par
nos partenaires CSA et Cisco vous le
voyez
16,3 % ce qui est très faible et il y a
5 quand lors du premier tour de la
présidentielle le 21 avril 2002 le taux
définitif d'abstention était beaucoup
plus élevé puisqu'il était de 28,4 %
près de 3 électeurs sur 10 ne s'étaient
pas déplacés en 1995 le taux
d'abstention était de 21,6 % en fait
pour retrouver un chiffre aussi bas il
faut remonter à
1965 et la première élection
présidentielle au suffrage universel
merci Audrey Roland Carol cette année
l'institut CSA s'est donc associé à
Cisco pour nous d' offrir les les
estimations et les chiffres les les plus
fiables euh c'était pas simple hein
puisque en raison de de
l'hésitation de l'indécision des des
électeurs et peut-être même jusqu'au
dernier moment les enquêtes on ont dû
être difficiles oui on a vraiment eu le
sentiment parfis qu'on sondait sur du
sable ou sur des plaques tectoniques qui
bougeaient sans arrêt euh bon sur les
estimations en revanche on sait qu'on
travaille sur des résultats de bureau de
vote réels et de bulletins dépouillés
donc je pense que en revanche à 20h on
pourra avoir confiance au point près oui
parce que l'estimation que que vous
donnez à 20h généralement elle est elle
est très très proche du résultat final
tout à fait l'abstention on peut
s'écarter encore d'un point ou deux mais
vraiment sur les résultats qu'on vous
annoncera à 20h pile je pense qu'on sera
très proche sur chacun des 12 candidats
de de son résultat final enfin touche du
bois alors c ça travaille et dans les
bureaux de vote on travaille aussi
puisqueon on dépouille les les votes oui
le le dépouillement a commencé dans les
villes où le vote s'est arrêté à 18h
voyons les images de dépouillement dans
un bureau de vote de Strasbourg j'ajoute
que pour ceux qui votent dans les
grandes villes où les bureaux de vote
ferment à 20h on nous signale parfois de
longues attentes hein 1h 1h3 d'attente
dans les bureaux de vote où il y a des
machines électroniques et bien tous ceux
qui sont présents dans le bureau de vote
à 20h pourront voter au-delà de 20h
qu'il qu'il le reste donc dans la file
s'ils souhaitent voter ils pourront
voter même si l'heure de 20h arrive
alors nous allons vivre cette soirée en
grande partie grâce à nos envoyés
spéciaux grâce à nos correspondants en
région qui depuis une vingtaine de de
points de direct sont interviendront
tout au long de cette soirée parmi
Patrice machouré qui se trouve l'UMP
Nicolas Sarkozi va arriver est
arrivé ben écoutez non il il se fait
attendre à priori il devrait parler vers
20h10 vous l'entendez sans doute he
l'ambiance monte c'est plutôt chaud dans
tous les les sens du terme d'ailleurs
dans cette salle gavo il y a des écrans
qui sont installés dehors des caméras
parce que un certain nombre de gens sont
rue de la boessie puisque beaucoup
beaucoup arrivve la rue de la boessie
est libre au public donc beaucoup
beaucoup de gens viennent et évidemment
les images de l'extérieur sont projetées
à l'intérieur les images de l'intérieur
sont projetées à l'extérieur donc autant
vous dire que pour l'instant on est en
vasclos et Nicolas Sarkozi j'espère va
venir pour rencontrer tous ces militants
qui l'attendent vous l'avez compris de
pied ferme bon c'est un vrai clip chez
vous merci on va maintenant aller voir
l'ambiance rue de l'Université au QG de
de François Beyrou nous attend Daniel
Sportiello quelle est l'ambiance Daniel
écoutez il y a une drôle d'ambiance ici
rue de l'Université où la soirée
électorale se déroule en plein air il y
a bien quelques jeunes qui s'échauffent
un peu mais les supporterurs de François
Baayou qui sont arrivés maintenant ne
s'expriment pas sont suspendus au
résultat du 20h François bairou qui est
arrivé lui aux alentours de 18h ne s'est
pas exprimé il est dans son bureau réuni
avec des parlementaires derrière moi
vous voyez une tribune sur fond orange
orange la couleur de la Révolution
tranquille voulue par l'UDF c'est de
cette tribune que François Baayou
s'exprimera après 20h pour son grand
discours de la soirée électorale merci
Daniel alors nous allons poursuivre
notre tour d'horizon des QG des
candidats où en tout cas des des lieux
de de rassemblement direction l'équinoxe
dans le 15e arrondissement de Paris où
se trouve éc tibaau pour le Front
national alors Jean-Marie Le Pen vient
d'arriver il est arrivé il y a 2 3
minutes mais pour l'instant il n a
toujours pas de militant ni de leader du
Front national ici donc Jean-Marie Le
Pen devrait faire une déclaration très
vite après 20h je vous rappelle l'enjeu
pour lui c'est évidemment de faire aussi
bien qu'en 2002 ce qui ne sera pas
facile avec cette très forte
participation d'aujourd'hui merci Éric
nous allons dans les Deux Sèvres Amel le
fief électoral de segégolen royale
Marie-Pierre courtellmont où est la
candidate du PS où est-elle que
fait-elle que
dit-elle la candidate date du du PS est
toujours dans sa maison à quelques
dizaines de mètres de l'endroit où je
vous parle je suis actuellement dans
l'école maternelle de Mel où se sont
rassemblés plusieurs centaines de mélois
venus d'une part écouter les résultats
de leur communes qui sont tombé je peux
d'ors et déjà vous dire quand même que
c'est Golen royale bien évidemment il a
obtenu un très large score et puis à 20h
ils vont écouter avec beaucoup
d'attention sur notre antenne je
l'espère sur les écrans géants les
résultats nationaux de la candidate de
leur fief et ensuite ils vont rester
encore certainement une demi-heure
puisqu'à 20h30 c'est Goolen Royal
viendra ici s'exprimer parler au
français par l'intermédiaire de la
télévision avant de se diriger vers la
ville de nior d'où elle doit prendre un
avion pour rejoindre Paris dans la
soirée elle est actuellement accompagnée
dans sa maison elle sera accompagnée
lors de son voyage voilà merci
Marie-Pierre alors la tension monte Amel
monte dans les QG monte aussi ici sur le
plateau à France I j'imagine que
chez vous aussi la tension monte en
famille ou entre amis les invités sont
sont arrivés audre Jean-Michel alors nos
premiers invités sont là Louis et
pendant toute la soirée d'autres
viendront prendre un peu leur place et
c'est c'est la règle du jeu pour les
soirées électorales parmi ceux qui sont
déjà arrivz àambouquet bonsoir vous
représentez le le Parti communiste
Jean-François coupé bonsoir êes
représentant de Nicolas Sarkozi sur ce
plateau Noël Mamère devrait nous
rejoindre Carl Lang bonsoir vous êtes le
vice-président du Front national jeanich
je vous laisse présenter nos autres
invités Jean-Louis Bianco qui représente
ici cgolen royale Clémentine hetin
apparenté communiste adjointte au maire
de Paris qui nous parlera de la gauche
de la gauche et de peut-être cette
opération manquée de la gauche et puis
Jean-Christophe Lagarde qui représente
ici François Baayou merci et merci à
vous d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
nous allons aller du côté de Lille où
nous attends pierre Yv grrenu Lille la
ville de Martine au de Pierre mourois
une ville qui qui j'imagine espère un
beau score de c'est Goolen Royal
oui c'est une région traditionnellement
de gauche mais qui en 2002 avait donné
son cœur ou en tout cas l'essentiel de
ses voix du premier tour avait mis en
tête Jean-Marie Le Pen dans les deux
départements du Nord et du pastecalais
et ici en particulier ça avait vraiment
été un séisme l'enjeu sera donc ce soir
notamment de savoir si le Front national
se maintient à pareil niveau un mot sur
la participation qui est tout à fait
voisine de la tendance nationale ici
dans le Nord comme dans le Nord p comme
dans le P decalis plus 11 % de
participation à 17h c'est-à-dire un
chiffre très important malgré le beau
temps et ses tentations et malgré les
vacances puisqueici on est en plein cœur
des vacances de la zone B merci Pierre
du nord au sud nous allons retrouver à
Marseille HUG Girard pour prendre la
température du côté du du Vieux Port
comment comment se passe cette fin de
d'après-midi à Marseille
HUG et bien avec une participation très
élevée et on va surtout surveiller ici à
Marseille le score de Jean-Marie Le Pen
qui sur l'ensemble de la région
provinceable C d'Azur était arrivé en
tête devant Jacques Chirac et il se peut
que ce soir il en soit totalement
différent on pourrait avoir un transfert
de voix entre Jean-Marie Le Pen et
Nicolas Sarkozi ça on le sera dans
quelques secondes mais c'est en tout cas
le souhait des gens de l'UMP des élus de
l'UMP mais c'est en tout cas le le
résultat que l'on va suivre avec le plus
d'attention car il aura aussi des
répercussions sur les prochaines
élections du 2è tour bien sûr mais
législative également merci HUG Girard
nous retrouverons bien sûr tous nos
envoyés spéciaux tous nos correspondants
en région tout au long de de la soirée
une soirée qui va se poursuivre jusqu'à
1h du matin alors il est maintenant 19h
et presque 58 minutes autant dire que
dans 2 minutes il sera 20h ça sera la la
fin Jean-Michel bet d'un d'un long
suspense un suspense qui dure depuis des
mois ce premier tour était passionnant
et passionnant jusqu'au bout puisque
toutes les combinaisons étaient encore
envisageables d'abord je crois que
l'intérêt des é électeurs et des
téléspectateurs pour cette élection
était tout à fait indéniable on l'a vu
avec les grandes émissions politiques où
l'audience a été très très élevé on l'a
vu aussi avec la vente des journaux on
l'a vu aussi avec pour la première fois
peut-être pendant une campagne
présidentielle l'intérêt que la campagne
a suscité sur internet donc un intérêt
on parlait de la campagne avec ses amis
dans sa famille au restaurant bon voilà
on parlait de la campagne ça veut pas
dire d'ailleurs que la campagne est
satisfait tout le monde on verra ça ce
soir mais
on en a parlé alors on a vu aussi
pendant cette campagne un deuxième
phénomène c'était l'indécision
c'est-à-dire que Roland kérol tout à
l'heure parlait de plaque tectonique on
a vu jusqu'au dernier moment que les
électeurs pouvaient passer d'un candidat
à un autre d'autant plus facilement que
pendant cette campagne le clivage droite
gauche éétait considérablement estompé
et donc on pouvait passer d'un candidat
à l'eau d'un candidat de droite à un
candidat de gauche je vous interromps
quelques instants Jean-Michel car nous
avons les quatre quartiers généraux les
quatre QG des principaux candidats à
l'UMP au PS à l'UDF et au Front national
un écran divisé en quatre pour suivre
l'ambiance la joie l'explosion de joie
dans quelques secondes maintenant dans
le camp des vainqueurs des deux
vainqueurs et dans le camp des deux
vaincus puisque sans sauf énorme
surprise he les les deux vainqueurs sont
sont parmi C4 il est 19h59 et 22
secondes je vous laisse la parole encore
quelques instants Jean-Michel oui je
disais qu'il y avait eu une très grande
très grande indécision jusqu'au dernier
moment selon certains instituts de
sondage la moitié des électeurs ont pris
leur décision ce matin même en allant au
bureau de vote et un électeur sur trois
a pris sa décision entre hier et
aujourd'hui donc on on voit à quel point
le vote a pu bouger pendant ces
dernières 48 Hees et puis je dirais que
le dernier enseignement et on va le voir
dans quelques secondes c'est évidemment
le syndrome du 21 av atttion JeanMichel
je vous interrom puisque il est 20h et
nous voyons l'exlosion de joie dans
quelques instants qui va éclater du côté
de
l'UMP et du Parti socialiste puisque
Nicolas Sarkozi et sgolen Royal arrivent
en tête ce soir Nicolas Sarko crédité de
29,4 % cgolen royal pour le Parti
socialiste de 26,2 % loin derrière
arrive en 3e position et ratons ainsi la
seconde marche du podium François beayou
pour l'UDF avec 18,6 % suivi de jeanm Le
Pen crédité de 11 % donc voici le quiuor
de tête de ce premier tour audre voilà
et pour les autres candidats nous allons
découvrir ensemble les estimations de
nos partenaires CSA et Cisco pour les
résultats obtenus par les autres
candidats Olivier bezannau remporterait
4,6 % des suffrages Philippe Devillier
2,4 Marie-George Buffet 2% Dominique
voanet 1,5 %. il s'agit je vous le
rappelle d'estimation aret laguillet
remporterait 1,4 % des suffrages devant
Frédéric neous 1,2 José Bovet 1 % et
Gérard Chivardi 0,3 %. oui des scores
très faibles pour ces derniers candidats
je vous rappelle le chiffre concernant
les les quatre premiers notamment les
deux premiers qualifiés pour le second
tour qui se retrouveront face à face
dans 15 jours le 6 mai Nicolas Sarkozi
avec 29,4 % et sgolen royal avec 26,2 %
suivent François Beyrou pour l'UDF et
Jean-Marie Le Pen pour le Front national
alors qu'on voit l'ambiance derrière moi
dans les QG de l'UMP et du Parti
socialiste Roland Carol si vos
estimations sont justes et il n'y a pas
de raison qu'elle ne le soit pas ça veut
dire que ce soir les les électeurs les
Français ont choisi de de revenir à un
traditionnel duel droite gauche en tout
cas c'est ça qu'ils ont placé en tête de
leur suffrage on le sentait depuis
quelques semaines il y avait une volonté
de de pas réitérer un 21 avril et
d'avoir clairement la gauche et la
droite au second tour on avait un
tassement des voix de François Barou qui
est confirmé ce soir mais il y a à
chaque fois une petite surprise dans le
comportement de dernières minutes
d'isoloir des électeurs c'est ce qui
fait sans doute le charme et pour
d'autres le drame des élections cette
fois-ci c'est une nouvelle fois le Front
National qui nous surprend mais dans un
sens différent il n'y a que 11 % de
d'électeurs exprimés qui sont allés vers
le Front national
ce qui donne donc au total cette figure
avec ces deux candidats Nicolas Sarkozi
nettement en tête 3 points d'avance à
peu près 2,8 pour nous devant segolan
royale et ces deux-là sont les
incontestables compétiteurs du second
tour ils ont largement devancé François
Baayou et plus encore Jean-Marie Le Pen
merci on se retrouve dans dans quelques
instants Roland Carole pour d'autres
précisions d'autres analyses pertinentes
direction tout de suite le siège de
l'UMP la sal gavo où Nicolas Sarkozi a
recueilli donc je vous le rappelle
29,5 % des des suffrage selon
l'estimation CSA Cisco Patrice machuré
bon le suspense était mince mais
j'imagine que que la joie est intense ah
oui je pense que vous pouvez encore
l'entendre he je n'ose pas avec ce micro
faire écouter mais depuis 20h tout le
monde crie on a gagné d'ailleurs c'est
assez étonnant parce que c'est presque
une ambiance de second tour puisqu'il
arrive en tête vous l'avez avec 29 %
mais dans on va dire dans dans dans
l'ambiance d'ici on a vraiment le
sentiment que c'est gagné d'ailleurs
encore une fois ils le disent on a gagné
on est en finale on y va donc une
ambiance de liè alors la seule
incertitude maintenant c'est quand
Nicolas Sarkozi va-t-il venir personne
ne donne une heure on va dire fixe ou
correcte donc on l'attend d'ici 20
minutes une demi-heure on ne sait pas
encore merci Patrice alors l' MP est en
finale mais n'a pas gagné la finale
d'ailleurs Jean-Louis Bianco don donnera
son avis tout à l'heure face à lui
Jean-François Copé aussi cgolen ROYAL
arrive donc en tête ce soir et qualifié
pour le second tour je vous le disais
arrive en tête avec 26,3 % des voix nous
allons retrouver au siège du Parti
socialiste devant le siège du PS rue de
Solferino Catherine deanat Catherine
j'imagine que ça a été un grand ouf de
soulagement pour tous les les militants
présents sur place affiché sur notre
écran ce oui ici plusieurs milliers de
personnes ont salué par une immense
clameur l'annonce des deux finalistes
les gens ont crié on va gagner on va
gagner il faut dire que pour permettre à
tous ceux qui souhaitent de suivre cette
soirée électorale au plus près la rue de
Solferino est coupé à la circulation un
écran géant est installé juste devant le
siège du parti où son est retransmis
sont retransmises les différentes
soirées électorales organisées par les
télévisions et elles sont très très
bruillamment commenté alors
effectivement ici c'est un très grand
soulagement c'est la fin du cauchemar du
21 avril tout à l'heure tous les
éléphants du parti sont venus ici RS
Pino et se sont réunis pour étudier les
premiers résultats beaucoup sont encore
ici et voilà et sigolen royale vous le
savez arrivera après avoir fait une
déclaration solennelle à Mel elle
devrait arriver ici aux environs de 23h
voilà et Jean-François Copé Jean-Louis
Bianco et les autres invités pent
d'impatient sur ce plateau pour répondre
aux questions d'audre pulevard et de
Jean-Michel bliet alors Jean-François
Coppé bonsoir honneur j'allais dire en
tout cas celui qui arrive en tête de ce
premier tour votre candidat a réussi son
Paris pour le premier tour qui était
effectivement non seulement d'être
présent au second tour mais de virer en
tête pour reprendre son expression alors
est-ce que c'est gagné ah non c'est pas
gagné il y a deè tour là la seule chose
c'est que si je devais vous livrer
quelques premières réflexions d'abord ce
que j'ai constaté c'est un record absolu
de participation c'est colossal puisque
il faut revenir à je crois la première
élection présidentielle de 65 et surtout
et c'est ça qui me paraît très
intéressant des débats passionnés pour
l'essentiel sur les thèmes qui ont été
amenés par Nicolas Sarkozi c'est-à-dire
en particulier l'identité le pouvoir
d'achat nous avons fait une émission sur
votre chaîne il y a quelques semaines
sur ce thème et c'est vrai qu'on a vu à
cette occasion que c'était évidemment un
point sur lequel Nicolas Sarkozi tout au
long de la campagne a mené ces thème et
puis peut-être si vous le permettez une
deuxième deuxième remarque c'est que le
score qu'il va réaliser probablement en
valeur absolue c'est certainement l'un
des plus élevés qu'un candidat à droite
est jamais réalisé sous la 5e en attend
de voir cela c'est peut-être même mieux
que d'autes on va voir ce que ça donne
en valeur absolue de voix mais surtout
ce que je retiens dans le même temps
c'est que le Front National s'est
effondré et ça ça veut dire beaucoup de
choses notamment quand on regarde
l'histoire récente de la droite
française nous avons toujours refusé
l'alliance avec le frond national mais
alors ça su ça supposait une condition
majeure c'est d'être présent sur les
thèmes non pas du Front national les
thèmes désertés par la droite sur
lesquels il y avait une attente forte
des Français je pense à l'identité
Nicolas Sarkozi a dit à plusieurs
reprises qu'il souhaitait faire revenir
dans dans le giron de la droite
républicaine les électeur du Front
national est-ce que ce soir dans son
score il y a beaucoup de voix du Front
national selon vous écoutez en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que je vois d'un
côté un score très élevé pour Nicolas
Sarkozi qui représentait la droite et
une partie du centre et un effondrement
du Front National et juste simplement ce
que je veux dire c'est que nous l'avons
fait sans aucune complaisance avec les
responsables du Front national vous en
savez quelque chose on a subi des
torents d'injure de Monsieur Le Pen et
puis d'autre part que par contre sur le
fond la sécurité l'immigration
l'identité le le pouvoir d'achat autant
de sujets qui ont suscité des polémiques
même je crois un peu sur votre chaîne et
ben le moins qu'on puisse dire le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'on a mis les
pieds dans le plat et surtout et c'est
ça aussi la marque de fabrique de
Nicolas Sarkozy on a dit la vérité alors
car l vous représentez ici le front
national euh 10 % hein pour Jean-Marie
Le Pen euh c'est un échec ça veut dire
que la parenthèse du Front national est
en train de se refermer vous savez
depuis 20 ans on annonce que le Front
national va disparaître alors je sais
bien que cette fois-ci Monsieur Sarkozy
et ses amis avaient décidé de liquider
le Front national il voulait ass
assécher le Front national nous avons
reculé malheureusement mais nous sommes
toujours présent et je tiens à remercier
tout d'abord les millions d'électrices
et d'électeurs qui ont fait confiance au
à Jean-Marie Le Pen au candidat Front
National et qui ont bien fait de le
faire car ainsi ils peuvent peser sur la
vie démocratique de notre pays sur
l'avenir de la France et sur ce deuxème
tour parce qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
malheureusement dans le pire des
scénarios c'est-à-dire que nous avons le
choix entre les sortants de l'UMP et les
revenants socialistes c'està-dire que
dans tous les cas de figure nous allons
en reprendre pour 5 ans et c'est donc
c'était donc essentiel que ces millions
d'électeurs marquent tout même car l
langue en en 5 ans le Front national si
on ajoute le score de Jean-Marie Le Pen
et de Bruno Maigret perd la moitié quasi
de ses écteurs peut-être pas tout à fait
parce qu'il y avait plus d'inscrits
cette fois-ci mais enfin la moitié en
pourcentage certains on ont
manifestement été abusés des promesses
électorales de Monsieur Sarkozi mais je
préfère moi voir le le verre à moitié
plein que le vert à moitié vide et je
tiens surtout à rappeler que nous sommes
toujours là et que malgré les promesses
la démagogie de la campagne électorale
la thématique sur l'identité nationale
ça fait 30 ans que Jean-Marie Le Pen
parle de l'identité nationale monsieur
Sarkozi ça fait 3 mois et bien malgré
tout cela nous sommes toujours présents
et nous serons présents dans les urnes
au deième tour et aux élections
législatives Jean-Louis Bianco c'est la
fin du cauchemar comme le disent
certains de vos militants c'était pas un
cauchemar je crois que cette campagne a
été difficile mais a été joyeuse aussi
je parlais du cauchemar de de 2002 2 oui
mais en effet on a effacé cette cette
triste date mais le plus important je
crois c'est la merveilleuse nouvelle
pour la démocratie cela a été dit vous
l'avez dit d'autres l'ont dit on est
probablement au niveau de 1965 a que la
première élection présidentielle de la
5e République alors qu'on disait que les
Français s'abstenaient qui
s'intéressaient plus à la politique qui
n'y croyaaient plus et moi je trouve ça
vraiment merveilleux à nous bien entendu
de ne pas les décevoir et permettez-moi
de dire que c'est une première victoire
pour ccèes Royal qui dès le début s'est
adressé au français directement qui a
vit la démocratie participative au cœur
de sa démarche qui a rassemblé 3
millions de personnes pour construire
son pacte présidentiel et ça je crois
que c'est une contribution importante au
fait qu'aujourd'hui les Français ont
pris la parole et croyez-moi avec royale
il continueront à la garder merci
Jean-Louis Bianco alors il y a ce soir
les deux vainqueurs ceux qui sourient à
l'UMP et au Parti socialiste et puis il
y a les vaincus et parmi eux et bien
François Beyrou qui rate son Paris de
monter sur la deè marche du podium
Daniel Sportiello j'imagine que le coup
est rude du côté du candidat centriste
oui écoutez peu avant 20h on entendait
encore les jeunes supporters scandé des
François président François Baayou
président puis après annonce des
résultats à 20h évidemment immense
déception chez ces jeunes qui pensaient
que la grande mobilisation que l'on a vu
aujourd'hui dans les urnes profiteraient
à leur champion qui avait mis tous ses
espoirs sur les jeunes et les indécis
mais enfin on se console quand même en
disant que François Baayou est le trè
homme et qu'avec le score qu'il a fait
il a désormais un rôle incontournable
dans la vie politique
française Jean-Christophe lagard
réaction pardon Louis une réaction à ce
score décevant pour François Baayou qui
s'imaginait gagner l'élection écoutez
décevant quand vous partez de 6 % et
vous arrivez autour de 20 quand vous
avez 2 millions de voix en 2002 et
aujourd'hui plus de 6 millions peut pas
dire que ce soit décevant ce qui se
passe ce soir il y a de bon nouvelle la
première bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'effectivement l'extrême droite recule
et divise quasiment par deux la deuxième
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il y a une force
politique nouvelle qui qui né on a voulu
proposer aux Français de ne plus voter
par réflexe mais par réflexion de ne
plus rester dans leurs famillees
politique qui se font la guerre et qui
finalement se stérilisent mais de sortir
et 6 millions de gens dont on le verra
sans doute la moitié venant des rangs de
la gauche la moitié desevenenant des
rangs traditionnels de la droite qui
disent oui on veut changer et bien pour
nous c'est une bonne nouvelle il y a 6
mois si vous m'aviez interrogé vous
auriez dit à quoi ça sert qui se
présente aux élections ça sert à faire
se lever ce peuple de France là qui veut
qu'on change enfin les choses et on va
leur permettre de le faire en de
temprist Lagarde la question que tout le
monde va vous poser ce soir c'est
qu'est-ce que vous faites de ces 18 %
hein vous avez vous venez de dire que
ces électeurs viennent à la fois de la
droite et de la gauche qu'est-ce que
vous en faites ces électeurs ils
viennent d'abord pour changer la vie
publique pour changer la stérilisation
de la vie publique par des débats
factices qu'on entend et qui finalement
une fois au pouvoir ne change pas
grand-chose et bien nous allons faire
deux choses la première leur permettre à
cette franceche orange de pouvoir
continuer à s'exprimer à grandir à
croître et à embellir et puis la
deuxième chose vous avez pour ça
évidemment les élections législatives
qui arrivent et puis la deuxième chose
c'est que nous allons réfléchir dans
l'entre deux tours à la meilleure façon
non seulement de les faire entendre mais
de les faire respecter parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'électeurs et notamment cux ce
soir vous ne savez pas ce que vous irez
ce que vous direz à ces 18 % d'électeurs
qui ont voté pour Fr il y a beaucoup
d'électeurs qui en ont assez de se faire
marcher dessus par des fausses promesses
et pour le compte on a fait une campagne
en évitant les fausses promesses les
dépenses à tier larigot qu'on était en
train de nous annoncer qui n'auront
jamais lieu et là-dessus il y aura
beaucoup de déçus duutin de ce soir et
on va faire en sorte au cours non
seulement de l're de tour mais des
élections législatives parce que c'est
là que se décidera la majorité
gouvernement
conséencesé nous all prendre la dire du
Front national pour entendre un autre
déçu de la soirée le FN qui avait loué
une grande salle dans le 15e
arrondissement j'ai lu que que 1500
bouteilles de champagne étaient au frais
elles ne seront sans doute pas toutes
débouché ce soir tiibo non elles ne
seront pas débouché effectivement on
attendait 1500 militants ou
sympathisants du Front National et je
peux vous dire que ce soir il y a
peut-être tout au plus de à 300
personnes il y a essentiellement des
journalistes et des techniciens dans
cette salle alors évidemment c'est un
échec pour le Front national ça veut
également dire que Nicolas Sarkozi a
réussi son Paris c'est qu'il a réussi à
récupérer des électeurs qui en 2002
avait voté pour le Front National et je
pense que ce soir la soirée évidemment
sera assez courte ici au siège du Front
national Jean-Marc qui le président du
groupe socialiste à l'Assemblée qui
vient de nous
rejoindre à l'instant Jean-Christophe
Lagarde disait qu'il allait ne pas
laisser perdre au fond ces électeurs qui
ont voté pour François baayrou est-ce
que vous au Parti socialiste vous avez
des choses ce soir à dire à ces
électeurs de François Baayou moi j'ai
des choses à dire à à tous les Français
qui veulent vraiment le changement parce
que je pense qu'ils sont la majorité
dans dans notre pays le vote de ce point
de vue il il est très éclairant il y a
un candidat qui était le seul candidat
d'ailleurs assumé qui représentait la
majorité sortante le gouvernement
l'action du gouvernement qui est un
échec l'injustice et l'efficacité ça
c'est il faut pas l'oublier donc la le
deuxème tour c'est une deuxième élection
c'est une nouvelle élection qui commence
et là les Français ont voulu effacer
2002 le 21 avril ils se sont donnés les
possibilités de choisir entre deux
projets deux personnalités deux méthodes
deux méthodes et c'est extrêmement
important donc je pense que parmi tous
ceux qui n'ont pas voté pour ces goen
royale mais ils ont été nombreux à le
faire parce qu'ils ont voulu absolument
que la gauche soit qualifiée au second
tour et ça c'est très important il y en
a beaucoup il y en a beaucoup dans les
différents partis de gauche il y en a
beaucoup y compris sûrement chez les
électeurs de François Berrou qui ne
veulent pas de cette méthode en gros la
méthode de Sarkozi c'est je décide et
les Français vous êtes en train de nous
dire que la campagne du second tour ça
va être tout sauf Sarko non pas
seulement parce que il suffit pas de
battre Sarkozi il faut aussi et c'est le
sens du pacte présidentiel de seggolen
royale faut transformer ce pays pour le
rendre plus fort plus juste mais pour ça
il y a une méthode et et la méthode de
Sarkozi elle est dure elle est brutale
et je pense que les Français n'en
veulent pas il y a beaucoup de candidats
qui l'ont dénoncé et on va bien voir ce
qui va se passer au deème tour mais je
le répète le deuxème tour c'est une
nouvelle élection qui commence et si
vous permettez je vous ajouter quelque
chose ça serait quand même
extraordinaire que quelqu'un qui
représente la majorité sortante qui a
échoué tous les clignotants sont au
rouge qui ait une sorte de prime qui lui
soit attribué une sorte de prime
Forgeard quoi hein on lui attribuerait
la prime forgard à quelqu'un qui a
totalement échoué donc si les Français
le veulent ils se sont donnés les moyens
de ne pas permettre ça de ne pas
permettre que Nicolas Sarkozy soit
président de la République et que c'est
gen Royal soit elle président de la
République pour une autre politique
monsieur vous faites un bel effort enfin
dites-moi à ceci près quand même
derrière cette belle démonstration que
tout l'exercice de diabolisation que
vous avez fait pendant toute cette
campagne pour expliquer que on était les
pires des pires que c'était
véritablement épouvantable mais il y a
quand même eu sacré nombre de millions
de Français qui a quand même fait la
démonstration que ce discours du PS qui
est un bon vieux discours à l'ancienne
avec par ailleurs des proposition que
les Français ont largement rejeté ça a
pas tellement marché votre affaire parce
que quand je fais le total des des des
intentions de vote t qu'elles ont été
sortis par les différents instituts de
sondage qu'est-ce que je vois je vois un
Nicolas Sarkozi qui malgré tout ce
discours hyper agressif à son endroit
fait un score qui premièrement est le
plus important jamais réalisé à droite
depuis très longtemps et puis
deuxièmement qui met quand même en échec
une candidate qui avait pour le coup
plutôt rassemblé la gauche alors si vous
le permettez de ce point de vue quand
même je crois que ça vaut peut-être la
peine d' regarder à deux fois il me
semble quand même qu'on a fait là la
démonstration d'un projet quand même
assez ambiux et assez rassembleur pour
le score réalis nous allons s'il vous
plaît avoir le temps de de débattre un
peu plus tard j'aimerais que l'on parle
du score du 5e puisque nous avons
aborder le prer le 2e le 3e et le 4e et
bien le 5e c'est Olivier besancenau ce
soir avec 4 u 6 % des voix selon les
estimations de nos partenaires CSA Cisco
Véronique Jean est au QG de d'Olivier
besancenau qui donc arrive en tête de la
gauche de la gauche Olivier besancenau
oui oui vous l'entendez derrière moi
l'ambiance est à la satisfaction ici ce
soir les militants applaudissent à tout
rompre à l'annonce de l'estimation du
score d'Olivier besanau tout le monde
était extrêmement joyeux an arrive donc
arriverait donc en 5e position il serait
le premier des petits candidats et
surtout le premier devant tous les
autres représentants de la gauche
antilibérale autre motif de réjouissance
ici le score annoncé pour l'instant de
Jean-Marie Le Pen qui serait moins élevé
que prévu quant au second tour et bien
si de jeunes militants disent encore
hésiter la majorité annonce qu'elle
votera c'est Golen royale la LCR veut
faire barrage à Nicolas
quant à une éventuelle gauche de
gouvernement une gauche plurielle B les
militants disent clairement non ils ne
veulent pas être achetés contre un
strapontin ministériel ils veulent
continuer à se positionner à la gauche
de la gauche pour obtenir les réformes
profondes qu'il demande merci Véronique
Jon alors on l'a vu on l'a entendu on
l'a compris la la joie dans le camp
d'Olivier besancenau en revanche nous
allons aller voir l'ambiance du côté des
vers Dominique voanet qui réalise un
tout petit score comme les les sondages
le prévoyaient 1,5 % les estimations de
CSA Cisco Sandrine Rigo j'imagine que
chez les vers c'est la soupe à la
grimace ce
soir je vous entends très mal mais je
peux vous dire que la déception est très
grande ici pas de larme l'ambiance est
plutôt conviviale il faut dire qu'on s'y
attendait un petit peu les rumeurs ont
commencé à circuler très tôt et puis vu
les derniers sondage de Dominique
vananet personne honnêtement ne
s'attendait à un miracle la dernière
fois qu'un candidat écologiste a fait
moins 2 % c'était en 1974 c'est dire
quand même l'ampleur du désastre pour
les vers alors la candidate écologiste
devrait faire une déclaration d'une
seconde à l'autre elle devrait notamment
se prononcer sur sa position au au
second merci on se retrouve un petit peu
plus tard puisque nous voyons en direct
les images de l'arrivée de Nicolas
Sarkozi donc qui arrive pour faire la
première sa première déclaration de de
la soirée grosse bousculade évidemment
aveous les
cam les photographes pour l'arrivée du
candidat de de l'UMP qui ce soir V donc
en tête nous vous le disions avec
29,5 % des voix selon les estimations de
CSA Cisco les militants sont sont très
nombreux dans dans l'attente de leur de
leur de leur
favoris nous entendons tout de suite la
déclaration de mariejorge buffet pardon
mariejorge buffet la candidate du Parti
communiste que nous allons entendre pour
sa première déclaration de la soirée
marjarge buffet crédité de 2 % vote dit
utile qui a joué massivement en faveur
de ces dolenes royal et même pour une
part de François berou il a
particulièrement joué sur les électrices
et les électeurs les plus déterminés à
faire gagner la gauche et notamment un
grand nombre d'électrices et d'électeurs
communistes ces résultats ne sauraient
traduire l'audience réelle du Parti
communiste dans notre pays
[Applaudissements]
comme je l'ai
dit comme je le dis depuis le début de
cette
campagne Nicolas Sarkozy est un homme
dangereux pour nos droits sociaux et
pour nos droits
démocratiques il a délibérément choisi
de de reprendre les thèses
insupportables du Front national afin de
devenir aujourd'hui le candidat de la
droite et de l'extrême droite il doit
absolument être
battu
Bouet marieorge qui va sans doute
appeler à voter pourgolen
royale
lucide lucide sur les insuffisances et
les ambiguïtés du programme de la
candidate socialiste j'appelle sans
hésitation tous les hommes et toutes les
femmes de gauche toutes et tous les
démocrates à voter et à faire voter le 6
mai cgolen
royale voilà marie-jorge buffet qui
appelle donc à voter pour la candidate
socialiste Marie-George Buffet ému 2 %
et 2 % qu'elle souhaite voir attribuer à
sgolen Royal au 2ème tour oui
marie-jorge buffet effectivement
manifestement très ému Alain bequet par
ce score 2 % des des voix selon nos
premières estimations c'est encore moins
qu'il y a 5 ans oui mais ça représente
pas l'audience réelle du du Parti
communiste et son influence dans le pays
je les législatives en témoigneront je
simplement dire que tout a été organisé
pour qu'il en soit ainsi hein la bande
des quat la chape de plomb médiatique
les débats qui ne sont pas venus en fait
l'Europe exite on n pas parlé de
l'Europe depuis depuis 1974 quand
mêmeés oui oui mais vous savez comme le
disait favill au lendemain de la chute
du mur de Berlin où tout le monde disait
les communistes sont morts méfiez-vous
ce sont des animaux constitués pour
traverser de long hi je vous concède que
l'hiver est un peu long mais
rassurez-vous nous ser toujours présents
pour être côté du monde du travail et de
la création pour défendre sa dignité et
la faire respecter ce que je veux dire
au passage d'abord je voudrais féliciter
les militants et les élus communistes
qui se sont battus dans cette bataille
merci Monsieur B pardon de vous
interrompre priorité au direct priorité
au direct puisque Dominique boanet
s'apprête à faire sa déclaration un
deuxième soutien potentiel de pour ces
Golen royal mais alors là c'est tout sa
c'est tout SAU Dominique boet donc je
vous rends la parole et dominiquez sera
avec nous dans quelques instants on va
se tourner vers clémentinetin qui est
apparenté communiste et qui elle avait
souhaité au début de cette campagne
qu'il y ait une candidature commune des
antilibéraux cette candidature n'a pas
eu lieu aujourd'hui on voit le résultat
José Bovet fait 1 % le Parti communiste
on vient de le voir fait 2 % donc c'est
un échec ah ben c'est sûr que il y a des
bonnes nouvelles d'abord et j'aimerais
commencer par là dans cette campagne
d'abord la la forte mobilisation et
l'intérêt des Français pour le débat
politique on l'a vu avec des meetings
bondés des audiences d'émission record
et ça je crois que ça fait extrêmement
plaisir et cette participation fait
plaisir et dans ce que les Français
attendent je pense qu'ils attendent des
réponses neuves et malheureusement dans
le C de la gauche antilibérale il y a eu
une promesse importante avec la
candidature unitaire avec le mouvement
des collectifs et que cette promesse n'a
pas été tenue et qu'aujourd'hui je suis
extrêmement triste de constater que nous
sommes finalement cantonnés à des petits
scores qui ne correspondent pas à ce que
représente je pense dans ce pays la
gauche de gauche une gauche antilibérale
une gauche sur d'elle-même fière
d'elle-même mais qui a aussi besoin de
se réinventer car il faut préciser
quitin que mis à part Olivier besancenau
qui fait à peu près le score qu'il avait
fait en 2002 à une décimale près tous
les autres s'effondrent y compris
harlette lagaguill et donc c'était la 6e
campagne je crois qu'on peut pas se
réjouir de cet effondrement et que ça
doit excusez-moi mais nous mettre un
coup de pied dans le derrière pour se
dire qu'il faut maintenant reconstruire
il s'agit pas simplement d'être triste
face à quelque chose qui n'a pas existé
il faut maintenant regarder devant la
première chose c'est que nous avons 15
jours pour battre Nicolas sarkooszi et
ça ça veut dire qu'il faut être clair il
faut appeler à voter pour seégolen
royale et la gauche d'alternative la
gauche antib je vous interrom je vous
interrom une seconde puisque Nicolas
Sarkozi vient à l'instant d'arrivé à la
sal gavo on l'a vu et il va faire sa
déclaration les
[Applaudissements]
coup Nicola Nicola Nicola Nicol
nicolcces chers
compatriotes mes chers
compatriotes ce soir le peuple de France
s'est
exprimé il s'est exprimé avec
clarté après tant de scrutins marqués
par la montée de l'abstention ce premier
tour l'élection présidentielle est une
victoire pour notre
démocratie en se rendant mass aux urnes
les Français ont exprimé leur volonté de
ne laisser personne décider à leur place
en me plaçant en tête de ce premier
[Applaudissements]
tour et en plaçant Madame Royale en 2è
position ils ont marqué clairement leur
souhait d'aller au bout du débat entre
deux idées de la nation deux projets de
société de système de valeur deux
conceptions de la politique ce débat
nous avons la responsabilité Madame
Royale et moi de faire en sorte qu'il se
déroule dans la clarté dans la sincérité
dans le respect des personnes nous avons
le
devoir de donner à travers ce débat une
image de
dignité qui soit à la hauteur de la
dignité de la fonction
présidentielle pour ma part je ne
changerai pas de ligne de conduite je
veux dire dire à Madame Royale que je la
respecte que je respecte ses convictions
et que je souhaite que le débat de ce
second tour soit véritablement un débat
d'idée les Français
l'attendent les Français l'attendent
depuis trop longtemps les Français le
réclament avec trop de force pour que ce
débat d'idée soit dénaturé alors au 11
millions d'électeurs qui ont voté pour
moi au premier tour par se sont
reconnus dans les idées que j'ai
exprimé je veux dire merci et un merci
qui vient du plus profond de mon cœur
ils m'ont fait confiance je veux leur
dire que je ferai tout pour être digne
de cette confiance tout au long de la
campagne j'ai souhaité m'adresser à tous
les Français bien au-delà des partis
j'ai voulu parler à ceux auxquels on ne
parlait plus j'ai voulu parler aux
travailleurs aux ouvriers aux employés
aux artisans aux agriculteurs à la
France qui donne beaucoup et qui ne
reçoit jamais rien à la France qui est
exaspérée et qui souffre celle des
banlieux en difficulté des bassins
industriels en déclin des cantons ruraux
abandonné j'ai voulu mettre au cœur de
la politique des valeurs qui me sont chè
l'identité de la nation l'autorité le
travail le mérite j'ai voulu parler de
morale j'ai proposé la valorisation du
travail l'école de l'excellence la
moralisation du capitalisme financier la
révolution du développement durable j'ai
dit que ma priorité était de donner à
chacun le moyen d'accomplir ses rêves de
réaliser ses ambitions de réussir sa vie
ces principes sont le fondement de mon
projet politique quels que soient les
obstacles je n'y renoncerai jamais je ne
les renirai jamais parce que je suis
profondément convaincu que l'avenir de
la France sa prospérité sa place dans le
monde en dépend comme en dépend le
bonheur des Français alors dans les 15
jours qui restent avant le second tour
je veux dire à tous les Français qui ont
peur qui ont peur de l'avenir qui se
sentent fragile vulnérable qui trouvve
la vie de plus en plus lourde de plus en
plus dure je veux dire à tous ces
Français que je veux les protéger je
veux les protéger contre la violence je
veux les protéger contre la V mais je
veux les protéger aussi contre la
concurrence déloyale contre les
délocalisations contre la dégradation de
leurs conditions de travail contre
l'exclusion je veux redonner aux
Français le goût d'entreprendre
d'innover le goût de l'aventure et
pourquoi pas le goût du risque je veux
pouvoir leur parler au français de
protection sans être accusé de
protectionnisme je veux pouvoir parler
de la nation française sans être accusé
de nationalisme au fond je veux à Tux
que la vie a brisé je veux parler aux
accidentés de la vie je veux parler à
ceux de nos compatriotes que la vie a
usé à ceux qui sont dans la détresse je
veux parler au malades au handicap aux
personnes âgées à ceux qu'un pression
trop forte a épuiser à tous ceux qui ont
trop souffert et bien moi je veux leur
redonner l'Espérance à chacun ils ont le
droit à l'espérance je veux leur dire
que la France dont je rêve
c'est une France qui ne laissera tomber
personne une France qui est comme une
famille où le plus faible le plus
vulnérable le plus fragile a droit à
autant d'amour autant de respect autant
d'attention que le plus fort une France
où même dans celui qui n'a plus de force
on reconnaît la dignité de l'homme et du
citoyen je veux m'adresser à tous les
Français pour leur dire que la société
du plein emploi est à mes yeux un moyen
parce que l'objectif c'est la société de
la pleine citoyenneté au fond mes chers
compatriotes je ne souhaite qu'une chose
rassembler le peuple français autour
d'un nouveau rêve français un rêve
français qui serait
ci un rêve un rêve
français qui est celui d'une république
fraternelle où chacun va trouver sa
place où personne n'aura plus peur de
l'autre où la diversité sera vécue non
comme une menace mais comme une richesse
cette France fraternelle dont je rêve
c'est la France qui m'a vu naître et
c'est celle qui m'a tout donné je lui
doit tout et bien il est venu le temps
pour moi de rendre à la France qui m'a
tout donné de lui rendre tout ce que je
peux lui donner moi-même cette France
fraternelle ce rêve français j'invite
tous les Français de bonne volonté quel
que soi leurs origines quel que soi leur
croyan quel que soit leur parti à s'unir
à moi pour qu'ensemble nous puissions la
bâtir mes chers compatriotes oui je vous
le dis du fond du cœur vive la
république et pardessus tout vive la
France voilà donc la première
déclaration en direct de Nicolas Sarkozy
qui a donc fait un rêve ce soir très
longue déclaration très longue
déclaration Nicolas sarzi en forme de
pour sa politique très à gauche par
rapport à ce qu'on a entendu par moment
pendant le premier tour Jean-Louis bioco
un commentaire bah c'était long parce
qu'il avait besoin de déverser des
tonnes de compassion sur à peu près
toutes les catégories chacun a eu droit
à son pe rappelle Jean-Paul i oui ce que
je crois surtout c'est que c'est quand
même énorme d'entendre ça quand on vient
de 5 ans d'un gouvernement qui a dressé
les Français les uns contre les autres
qui a soutenu le contrat le CPE qui ne
s'est pas attaqué au capitalisme
financier qui a laissé sa c'est le
pouvoir d'achat c'est exactement le
contraire de ce qu'il a fait pendant 5
ans et c'est aussi le contraire de ce
qu'il dit parce que il semble donner une
vision d'une France apaisée et en
réalité il oppose les fonctionnaires ou
non fonctionnaires ceux qui n'ont pas de
travail à ceux qui ont un travail donc
ce discours c'est tout le contraire de
ce qu'il a fait pendant 5 ans il faud
autre chose dans son discours il a
appelé à la clarté la sincérité et le
respect pendant la période de la
campagne du 2uxème tour le respect c'est
toujours ce que c'esten Royal a pratiqué
elle continuera bien entendu à le faire
bien entendu il faut que ce soit
symétrique des deux côtés alors avant
d'entendre la réaction de Jean-François
Copé j'aimerais écouter Noël maamère on
nous a pas encore entendu depuis le
début de cette émission une réaction
déjà au résultats de Dominique voanet et
aux différentes déclarations qu'on a
entendu et bien d'abord j'estime que le
résultat de Dominique voanet n'est pas
représentatif de l'élector vert elle a
été nous avons payé le vote utile et
cette volonté est manifestée massivement
par les Français de remettre dans les
placards de la République le mauvais
souvenir du 21 avril 2002
c'est quelque chose de positif de voir
que maintenant tout commence
c'est-à-dire que nous avons deux
candidats deux projets de société ce
soir seolen Royal a une responsabilité
particulièrement importante je considère
qu'à partir de ce soir elle n'est plus
la candidate du Parti socialiste mais
que d'ici le 6 mai elle doit devenir la
candidate de la gauche et des
écologistes ce soir nous ne nous
trompons pas nous savons qu'en face de
nous il y a une coalition Sarkozy Le Pen
car les mots utilisés par Monsieur Sar
mon pardon min mais on on a la réaction
de dominiqueis justement donc on va
l'écouter et vous allez terminer votre
propos je voterai le 6 mai pour ségolen
royale mon
soutien mon
soutien et sans
ambiguité mais les électeurs écologistes
se mobiliseront d'autant plus dans un
second tour qui s'annonce serré qu'elle
montrera qu'elle veut être désormais la
candidate d'une dynamique d'union qui ne
les exclut pas voilà donc une réaction
très très courte de Dominique voanet
Noël Mamère est-ce que vous pensez que
les les être en position ne pas être
exclu par les par les socialistes s'il
l'emportaiit les socialistes ne peuvent
pas gagner tout seul quand on regarde
les résultats de ce soir on voit que la
droite pèse massivement dans ce pays et
quand on fait la somme des voies de
droite on s'aperçoit qu'il va falloir é
une campagne durant le deuxème tour qui
soit une campagne basée sur les valeurs
sur un projet de société et qui montre
que toutes les composantes de la gauche
sont ensemble c'est tout à l'heure
monsieur Sarkozi parlait de respect le
respect nous avons l'habitude de le
pratiquer à gauche c'est maintenant
qu'il doit devenir une réalité et
maintenant que nous devons tous nous
mobiliser pour assurer la victoire de la
gauche au deuxème tour la victoire de la
gauche c'est pas gauche contre droite je
pense que les choses ont changé ce 22
avril 2007 ce sont deux projets de
société il y a un projet libéral et néo
au conservateur qui est celui de
Monsieur Sarkozi qui malgré ces
déclarations tout à l'heure qui sont une
sorte d'inventaire à la prévre où il ne
manque pas de culot en oubliant toutes
les lois qu'il a fait voter à
l'assemblée et contre lesquelles nousous
sommes battus avec détermination et puis
de l'autre il y a ségolen royale qui a
mené à la campagne pour le parti
socialiste et qui aujourd'hui doit mener
à la campagne pour l'ensemble de la
gauche et des écologistes sur un certain
nombre de propositions que nous avons
formulé et sur ces valeurs que nous
partageons je pense que les Français
veulent ce changement-là c'est celui-là
qu'ils ont exprimé aujourd'hui en en
participant à plus de 84 % dans ma ville
de beggle dans de nombreuses villes et
ce changement c'est pas recommencer avec
les mêmes c'est-à-dire avec Monsieur
Sarkozi et toute la clique qu'il a
soutenu pendant 5 ans c'est pas la
politique des clans qui doit continuer
mais c'est la politique au service des
Français no m on va continuer le le
débat pardonnez-moi la la campagne de
l'entre de tour comence a commencé ici
sur sur ce plateau c'est c'est
passionnant vous parliez de Dominique
voineet qui appelle donc à voter royale
Marie-George Buffet vous l'avez entendu
également appelle à voter sesgen royal
au deème tour marie-jorge buffet qui ce
soir selon les estimations de nos
partenaires CSA Cisco est crédité de 2 %
Serge Chimino vous êtes en direct du
siège du Parti communiste place Colonel
Fabien ambiance morose
j'imagine bah vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure Louis effectivement mariejorge
buffet a appelé sans ambage à voter pour
seolan Royal au deème tour mais malgré
dou en disant que le programme de la
candidate socialiste était un peu mou
pour une gauche qui s'est dite
antilibérale populaire voire
anticapitaliste en fonction de l'endroit
où on se trouvait pour autant
marie-jorge buffet vous l'avez entendu
aussi tout à l'heure disait dans son
allocution que ça ne pouvait être les
voix du Parti communiste qui était
compté ce soir pour autant c'est un
petit peu l'échec de marie-jorge buffet
qui pensait qu'en étant sous le label
gauche populaire antilibéral elle allait
rassembler au-delà de son camp ce soir
elle est bien loin des 3,37 de roberu il
y a 5 ans ça ce sera quand même
difficile à expliquer que ce ne sont pas
les voies communistes qui ont manqué ce
soir Louis merci Serge simino vous étiez
place du Colonel Fabien au siège du du
Parti communiste merci à vous alors à ce
stade oui audre oui non je je voulais
faire réagir Jean-François Copé à tout
ce qui a été dit depuis 10 minutes à
propos la déclaration de Nicolas Sarkozi
parce que j'imagine que vous ne partagez
pas la vision de Jean-Louis Bianco sans
vouloir complètement leur gâcher la
soirée j'ai entendu monsieur Bianco
socialiste parler après monsieur hos
socialiste sont mis à pour nous sonner
une charge monumentale sur Nicolas
Sarkozi expliquer finalement en vous
écoutant j'avais l'impression l'un et
l'autre vous aviez pas totalement vu ce
qui s'était passé c'est pour ça je veux
juste dire cette chose simple c'est que
pendant que vous vous continuez à
expliquer que vous êtes les très gentils
qui avaient raison et nous les très
méchants qui avont tous les défauts il y
a quand même une réalité qu'il faut
constater en ce soir de premier tour
c'est que malgré toutes les caricatures
que vous avez pu faire d'ailleurs avec
vos vos amis de de de gauche les Verts
et cetera qui aujourd'hui appelleent à
voter pour vous on verra ce qu'il en
sera de l'extrême gauche il n'empêche
que malgré tout ça et malgré ces
caricatures Nicolas Sarkozi a eu un
discours qui a rassemblé l'ensemble des
Français de toutes catégories et de
toutes origines moi j'en veux pour
preuve tout ce qu'on a pu entendre à
propos des banlieux on nous a expliqué
en long et en large qu'il avait un rejet
épouvantable moi je constate dans ma
propre ville de ma où nous avons 53 % de
logements sociaux des quartiers
difficiles Nicolas Sarkozi est venu il y
a pas très longtemps que Nicolas
sarkozizi qui est un score qui est même
un peu supérieur à ce qu'il semble avoir
fait au niveau national ce qui veut dire
quoi que nous avons profondément
renouveler notre démarche parce qu'il y
a une nouvelle génération qui a envie
aussi d'apporter un témoignage et une
volonté d'action et on l'a fait comment
en arrêtant la langue de bois en disant
la vérité je peux comprendre c'est la
raison pour laquelle je savais monsieur
hou que vous seriez sensible à cette à
cette démarche de ma part parce que je
savais que sur ce point ça nous faisait
peut-être une
différence oui écoutez moi je faut dire
des choses simples parce que le discours
de Nicolas Sarkozi là c'est
stupéfiant il est quand même le
représentant du gouvernement de la
majorité et avec le bilan que l'on sait
et qui a quand même été sanctionné sinon
vous auriez fait beaucoup plus monsieur
COP écoutez c'est quand même c'est un
fait politique pour un premier tour
c'est un record absolu on peut toujours
faire beaucoup plus c'est un record
absolu on va pas se battre sur les
chifres je vous rappelle simplement
giscar avait fait quelque chose d' peu
près similaire en 81 et qui a été battu
par François mitteran qui était à peu
près au m raép à l'époque Monsieur
mitteran avait fait beaucoup plus que
sesen Royal aujour reprenez pas ne
reprenez pas vos mauvaises habitudes
monsieur Copé je je termine juste pour
dire que là vraiment lors du vote du
second
tour tous ceux qui vont avoir à se
prononcer auront à se prononcer autour
du pacte présidentiel de Segolen royale
qui a pour but de rassembler et toutes
les bonnes volontés sont les bienvenus
et je pense à mes amis qui sont qui se
sont exprimés avant évidemment il faut
rassembler mais en même temps il faudra
avoir à l'esprit je pense que c'est
nécessaire les Français ne l'oublieront
pas le bilan de ce gouvernement et de
cette majorité tant en terme de contenu
de politique injuste ineff
et aussi de méthodes méthodes brutales
et ce qui a prévalu pendant 5 ans
Monsieur Sarkozi nous promet tout
simplement de continuer et ça je crois
que ça n'est plus possible alors bien
sûr il faudra changer il y a beaucoup de
choses à changer et la méthode de
sigolen Royal notamment la démocratie
participative la relance de la
démocratie sociale il y a de quoi faire
et rassembler toutes les forces
démocratiques de ce pays qui veulent
vraiment on va donner la parole à à
vouliez
réagirectivement ce qui est important
pour le second tour c'est un large
rassemblement des forces de gauche avec
une dynamique de gauche avec un contenu
un contenu antilibéral anticapitaliste
parce que pour l'instant c'est 36 % des
voix et la question qui est posée c'est
pas seulement une question de méthode
c'est que est-ce qu'on accepte de donner
les clés de la République à Monsieur
Sarkozi qui est quelque part le
représentant direct euh du CAC 40 euh du
MEF et de Madame Pariso c'est ça le fond
du problème est-ce qu'on va laisser
monsieur Sarkozi demain bonjour pour le
monde du travail et de la création
remettre en cause le le l'âge de la
retraite remettre en cause les services
publics remettre en cause le code du
travail ça a déjà été bien entamé sous
la précédente législature alors il faut
pas se tromper entre les beau les belles
parole rassurante d'une campagne
électorale don vous avez parlé dans le
passé souvenez-vous de la fracture
sociale est-ce qui attend ce qui attend
les Français et bien je crois qu'il faut
qu'ils réfléchissent qu'il pense
d'ailleurs à cette phrase qui avait été
dit dans le film de guépard ce célèbre
film de Visconti il fallait bien que
quelque chose change pour que tout
puisse rester comme avant on va rester
sur cette citation Monsieur B pardon de
vous interrompre pour la deuxième fois
vous allez croire que je non oui ça fait
deux fois il y en aura peut-être une
troisième mais je n'ai rien contre vous
c'est pour avancer dans le débat et à ce
stade de la soirée il me semble
intéressant Jean-Michel de de d'établir
les les comparaisons des des forces à
droite et à gauche alors moi c'est ce
qui me frappe dans ce dans cette soirée
dans ces résultats et dans ce débat
c'est-à-dire que au fond je vais mettre
tout le monde d'accord la droite comme
la gauche si on regarde le total pour la
droite hormi l'extrême droite on est aux
alentours de 31 % et si on regarde le
score de la gauche on est juste un petit
peu en dessous de 30 % et donc on voit
bien que Nicolas Sarkozi comme sgolen
Royal auront besoin de voix pour
franchir les 50 % au second tour moi
j'ai été
la
décationc une seule fois il parle de
françisou Monsieur Gouard vous nous
expliquerez peut-être pouroi
Jean-François Copé on ne parle pas de
François baayrou donc pour la gauche
comme pour la droite il faudra aller
chercher des électeurs pour rassembler
le camp Alain Boquet disait à l'instant
rassembler la gauche mais excusez-moi
avec un score comme celui de mariejorge
buffet et celui de Dominique
vouanet le rassemblement de la gauche me
paraît extrêmement difficile et
même extrême gauche ne fait pas un score
très très élevé ce soir elle est aux
alentours de 7 % donc ça sera
extrêmement difficile aussi bien pour
Nicolas Sarkozy que pour C Goolen Royal
nous allons entendre l'analyse de Roland
Carol pour les forces à droite
oui alors je ne sais pas si on va
découvrir quelques chiffres en même
temps ce qui est clair c'est que dans
l'analyse historique de du mouvement des
voix depuis quelques années on peut
jamais comparer exactement des choses
comparables parce que les configurations
de candidature ont été très différentes
alors évidemment voilà on voit ici la
répartition actuelle des forces dans
cette élection on voit qu'on a un total
des voix de strictement à droite de
Monsieur Sarkozi et de Monsieur de
Villier qui fait 31,9 bon c'est la
confirmation qu'il faut à partir de là
essayer de construire un électorat
second tour même si on ajoutait
l'ensemble des voix du Front national
dont on sait que les taux d'intention
REP sont très bon sur Nicolas sarzi on
arrive au total à peu près à 42 % c'est
mieux que ce que peut faire à gauche sur
le papier sur le papier c'est goen
royale puisque si on regarde les
résultats de l'ensemble des forces de
gauche on s'aperçoit que c'estan royale
alors là voilà on s'aperçoit que c'est
royale avec ses 26,3 % d'estimation fait
mieux que ne faisent les forces de la
gauche plurielle la dernière fois on
passe de 23,4 à
26,3 mais l'ensemble des forces de
gauche reste à un niveau très faible
37,1 et même si on pr on là aussi on
fait l'hypothèse que l'extrême gauche
vient tout entière on arrive dans les
EAU de 47 % grand maximum ce qui veut
dire qu'en effet pardon d'y insister
après Jean-Michel ce sont les électeurs
de François Baayou du premier tour qui
vont faire la différence l'essentiel de
la campagne va se faire au centre comme
dans beaucoup de de démocraties je pense
que le changement de discours qui a
commencé à amorcer Nicolas Sarkozy est
très significatif en la matière et il
vaut bien falloir que les socialistes de
leur côté se déterminent par rapport à
ces électeurs là on ne peut pas gagner
l'élection au deuxè tour même si c'est
une nouvelle élection si on ne conquiert
pas plus de la moitié des électeurs de
François Bayero d' aujourd'hui merci
Roland Carol alors tout ce que vous
venez de dire va nourrir évidemment le
le débat qui va se poursuivre ici sur ce
pl mais le le concept et la dynamique de
cette soirée c'est un incessant
aller-retour entre ici le plateau et et
l'extérieur et l'extérieur c'est
notamment clémment vénal qui se promène
dans dans les rues de Paris à la
découverte de de de l'ambiance de
l'atmosphère vous êtes place de la
Bastie apparemment oui on est en fait
rue de Lappe dans un bar sympathique le
bar des ferrailleurs où se confirme
l'effet Coupe du monde c'est-à-dire que
l'installation d'écran plasma attire
tous ceux qui veulent vibrer
collectivement à l'annonce des résultats
alors des résultats qui ont été
accueillis diversement il y a eu des
applaudissements des sifflets des Hu
mademoiselle vous êtes vous êtes content
des résultats ouais je suis très
contente que la gauche au second tour on
est un peu déçu par le score triste du
score de Sarkozi c'est dommage qu'il
fasse autant et on croit on espère
qu'elle va vraiment passer au second
tour et qu'elle va réussir à convaincre
tous les électeurs qui croi au
changement pour la France et non à SAR
piti
ouiilêes ven vous êtes venu pour
pourquoi vous n'z pas suivi la so chez
vous pourquoi vous préférez un bar ben
parce que c'est plus sypa on voit les
réactions de tout le monde et puis euh
ben là je crois qu'il faut que tout le
monde se mobilise donc pense que ça a
été entendu absolument VO voilà vous
voyez nous sommes nous sommes dans un
bar jeune et branché où je crois
quetivement des gens qui sont là sont
plus ou moins contents des résultats
voilà je vous retrouve tout au long de
la soirée dans d'autres lieux parisiens
merci clé attention il y a quelqu'un
derrière vous méfiez-vous alors plus
sérieusement nous allons entendre la
déclaration de Jean-Marie Le Pen euh au
PG du Front national Jean-Marie Le Pen
qui arrive ce soir à en 4e position avec
seulement 11 % des suffrages
contrairement à 2002 je vous propose
d'écouter le président du Front national
nous avons gagné la bataille des idées
la nation et le patriotisme
l'immigration et l'insécurité ont été
mises au cœur de cette campagne par mes
adversaires qui hier encore écartaient
ces notions
avec une mou dégoûtée cette victoire
idéologique est un acquis irréversible
du Front national dont je me félicite en
revanche je suis beaucoup plus inquiet
pour l'avenir de notre pays je crains en
effet que les Français naient été abusés
et je leur prédis avec tristesse des
lendemain qui déchantent ceux qui se
sont emparés des idées du Front national
ne l'ont fait que pour nous empêcher de
mettre en application les véritables
solutions à tous les problèmes
dramatiques qui menacent l'équilibre et
la prospérité de la France
contemporaine pour nous le combat au
service de notre pays et de nos
compatriote continue donc parce que la
seule façon de peser pour faire
appliquer la politique nationale que les
Français appellent de leur vœux c'est de
faire élire des députés Front national à
à l'Assemblée
nationale dans cette
perspective j'appelle tous nos
concitoyens à se mobiliser massivement
en faveur des candidats du Front
national pour les élection législatives
des 10 et 17 juin prochain et dès avant
je leur donne rendez-vous pour notre
grande et traditionnelle manifestation
du 1er mai à Paris en hommage à Jean d'c
symbole éternel du patriotisme français
c'est à cette occasion que je ferai
connaître notre mot d'ordre pour le
second tour merci alors ne vous
inquiétez pas Jean-François coupé il y
aura aussi dans tout au long de cette
soirée
l'expression d'électeurs plutôt
favoraable à
Nicolas aucun doute à ce sujetam au
doute à ce sujet et il va certainement
passer ne vous inquiétez pas pe même
souiter la victoire Nicolas sarzi même
AR mais restez avec nous je bouge pas
Bruno gnich plus sérieusement j'allais
dire une réaction à à ce que vient de de
déclarer Jean-Marie Le Pen il ne donnera
de consignes de vote s'il en donne qu'
qu'à partir du 1er mai oui c'est assez
naturel il faut d'abord examiner la
situation savoir ce que ce compte à dire
les deux candidats qui qui reste bien
sûr et il s'entourera
d'avis je pense qu'il a bien imposer le
problème à savoir que nos thèmes se sont
imposés mais malheureusement les
Français qui sont libres bien sûr de
leur choix ont préféré des candidats qui
ont qui représentent l'apparence du
changement plus que le
changement et ils ont un peu oublié un
peu vite qu'en fait monsieur Sarkozi est
l'héritier de de de Jacques Chirac et
Madame Royale celle de François mitteran
je pense électeurs se sont égarés
si si si nous avons un autre candidat et
une autre formation politique que Cell
qui sont arrivées en tête c'est parce
que nous pensons que celles qui sont
arrivées en tête dans ce scrutin ne ne
sont pas capables de proposer les
véritables solutions c'est vrai qu'ils
ont se sont largement inspiré
aujourd'hui de problématiques que nous
avons posé et qui étaient diabolisé à
l'époque et Don chacun reconnaît
aujourd'hui qu'elle qu'elle se posent au
pays mais en ce qui concerne
l'application des solutions je pense
ils ne le feront pas ils ne le feront
pas parce qu'ils resteront dans les
cadres actuels qui sont ceux du déclin
de notre pays guaum ptier vous êtes
proche de Philippe de Villier Philippe
de Villier fait ce soir aux environs de
2 et demi n'a pas réussi à trouver une
place entre l'électorat de jean-mie Le
Pen et Nicolas Sarkozy c'est une
déception tout le contraire c'est ce
soir pour moi et pour Philippe de un
grand sentiment de fierté le Mouvement
pour la France est le 6e parti politique
nous sommes en 6e position sur 12
candidats nous venons de franchir le
million de suffrage dans un contexte
difficile un sentiment de fierté de
travailler avec un homme Philippe de
Villier le plus courageux de tous qui a
osé dire des vérités plus haut que tout
le monde sur les dérives de l'Europe de
Bruxelles les dérives de l'européisme
les deux candidat du second tour je le
rappelle avait appelé à voter OUI à la
Constitution européenne la fierté
d'avoir un candidat qui est le seul à
défendre la famille la vie contre
l'avortement et l'euthanasie mais tout
de même qui fait moins qu'en 95 quand le
contexte a changé Rolan Kol l'a dit
d'acc
0ousousant aujourd'hui le Mouvement pour
la France est une grande force politique
et nous présenterons 577 candidats pour
second tour est-ce que vous allez
appeler à voter pour Nicolas Sarkozi
écoutez deux choses d'abord je voudrais
tourner la page de cette façon archaïque
de faire la politique qui consiste à
croire qu'on est propriétaire de ses
voix le million de Français qui a voté
Philippe de est bien libre et
suffisamment mature pour choisir qui est
le candidat le moins mauvais auelà de ça
c'est très bien je suis fier d'être de
droite je ne veux pas d'une gauche
archaïque dangereuse qui a semé le
trouble qui a mené notre société à la
faillite depuis 30 ans mais je me méfie
aussi beaucoup d'une droite frileuse qui
propage le communautarisme et
l'européisme donc vous appelez à voter
Nicola SARC c'est absolument pas ce que
je viens de dire j'ai dit liberté de
choix pour nos électeurs qui sont
suffisamment matures et libres merci
messieur nous allons repartir à
l'extérieur s'il vous plaît à
l'extérieur c'est même en dehors de
Paris parce que c'est la capitale des
Gaules oùon va retrouver en direct de
Lyon àain E lyon une ville dirigée par
le socialiste Gérard Colomb euh que
comment s'est passé cette cette soirée
l'annonce des des résultats
l'c ben à Lyon on a aucun résultat
actuellement ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que comme ailleurs la participation est
en Haus très forte dans toute la région
ronalpe et je vais vous donner un
exemple dans une commune du beaujela à
lierg il y a 1230 inscrits il y a eu 33
abstentions seulement c'est-à-dire 2,68
%
et puis alors sur Lyon même une anecdote
plusieurs électeurs français qui avaient
été expatriés qui étaient revenu en
France qui se sont réinscrits qui ont
reçu leur carte électorale leur matériel
électoral et bien ils ont été refoulé
des bureaux de vote pendant la journée
ils étaient plusieurs dizaines à Lyon et
puis vers 19h ceux qui avaient des
portables ont été rappelés ils ont pu
allez voter voilà merci an vous avez
toujours autant de de supporters à
Fourvière nous allons prendre la
direction de de Nantes qui va faire
plaisir à Jean-Marc Kud qui qui est sur
notre plateau Xavier ololland vous êtes
vous êtes anante quelle analyse
tirez-vous de ce premier tour de scrutin
du côté de Nantes B voyez à Nant place
du Commerce c'est calme pas de réaction
particulière tout à l'heure à l'annonce
des résultats nous sommes au cœur bien
sûr de de la ville de Nantes seul
chiffre pour l'instant notre possession
officielle c'est la participation avec
des chiffres très impressionn à 17h
alors que la moyenne nationale était de
73 % et bien ici dans les Pays de la
Loire on flirtait déjà avec les 80 %
certains départements avaient même
dépassé ces 80 % comme la Mayenne ou le
menéloir premier chiffre partiel pour
l'instant qui nous arrive d'abord
leement ville ville de gauche où Segen
oryal arrive en tête avec 31,67 % des
suffrages devant Nicolas Sarko 26 % en
vandz Nicolas Sarkozi arrive largement
en tête devant François Baayou un mot
d'ailleurs sur Philippe Devillier
candidat régional de cette
présidentielle dans le bureau numéro 8 à
hardardelé dans la commune des Herbiers
c'est le bureau où il vote et bien
Philippe Devillier n'a totalisé que
13,25 % des suffrage alors que Philippe
alors que berou et Sarkozi étaient
au-delà des 31 % et puis le menéir aussi
qui confirme l'arrivée en tête de
Nicolas Sarkozi devant François berou
alors que seg Royal serait en dessous le
menelir qui est bien sûr une tire
historique centriste merci merci à vous
nous allons tout de suite écouter en
direct la déclaration d'olivier en ceau
qui ce soir arrive donc en 5e position
avec 4,6 % des voix je vous propose
d'écouter le candidat de la LCR en
direct sur France 3 des voix je vous
propose d'écouter le
candidat all c'est bon chers amis chers
camarades c'est un grand moment de
fierté un grand moment de joie ce soir
pour nous et je tiens d'abord à
remercier tous les militants et toutes
les militantes de laalcr qu'on le chemis
pendant des
[Applaudissements]
mois et remercier aussi ceux et celles
qui sans être à la LCR ont participé à
cette campagne ce soir la LCR arrive en
5e position en récoltant 1
milli800000 électeurs
c'est-à-dire
c'est-à-dire 600000 de plus qu'en 2002
soit une progression de plus de 50 %
malgré la pression malgré la pression du
vote utile qui dans ces dernières
semaines a servi de seul programme au
Parti socialiste beaucoup ont eu le
courage de porter le surfrage sur mon
nom c'est un encouragement précieux et
efficace pour les luttes de demain nous
avons réussi ensemble dans cette
campagne au-delà du score à faire
entendre une voix une voix sociale qui
répondait aux attentes sociales des
couches populaires et notamment de la
jeunesse pour le droit à l'emploi
l'augmentation des salaires ou pour le
droit au logement pour un SMIC à 1500 €
net une augmentation des revenus à 300 €
nets pour la réquisition des logements
vides pour un service public de la
petite enfance ou du 4e âge ou pour
l'interdiction des licenciements sans
oublier la lutte nécessaire contre les
discriminations autant de questions
désormais installées dans la société et
dans le monde du travail autant de
mobilisation surtout à venir pour faire
entendre notre voix et faire entendre
notre force
personne n'est propriétaire de ces voix
et chacun et chacune est évidemment
libre de son vote le 6 mai mais depuis
plus de 5 ans la LC combat la politique
de Chirac et ses premiers ministres dans
la rue comme dans les urnes c'est
pourquoi ce soir je lance de nouveau un
appel à battre la droite dans la rue
comme dans les
urnes voilà c'est
clairivier a voté royale au 2è tour
Roland kérol nous allons revoir à
présent les estimations concernant les
les qure premiers de ce premier tour de
la présidentielle
2007 alors voici donc les les estimation
Nicolas Sarkozi a été donc encore un
petit peu réévalué avec l'arrivée
d'autres bureaux de vote de notre
échantillon des bureaux fermants à 20h
et franchit la barre symbolique des 30 %
avec 30 6 % des voix Segolen royale est
toujours en 2e position à
25,9 François baayrou
18,5 Jean-Marie Le Pen 10,8 vous le
voyez pas desécarts très important par
rapport à ce qu'on on vous avait dit à
20h mais psychologiquement
psychologiquement les écarts sont
toujours à prendre en compte quand on
prépare un second tour et l'écart entre
Nicolas Sarkozi et segan royal est un
peu plus élevé et il franchit de
surcroix la barre des des 30,6 % vous
remarquez d'ailleurs tout le monde c'est
la loi de la liturgie nouvelles des des
soirées électorales de premier tour tout
le monde est très content de ces
résultats et personne ne crie absolument
victoire parce que tout le monde sent
bien qu'il s'agit maintenant d'entrer
dans une campagne de second tour où ces
résultats dont les meilleurs résultats
sont très clairement ceux obtenus par
Nicolas Sarkozi ne sont pas ceux d'une
élection dans laquelle on peut prévoir
facilement un résultat àquis pour un
second tour bon merci pour ces
estimations qui étaient donc très très
proches qui sont très proches de de
celles que vous avez donné à 20h vous
faites vous avez raison de faire de
l'autosatisfaction parce que oui on a
assez tapé les journalistes les hommes
politiques sur sur les sondeurs donc
vous avez raison retour au plateau et
vous invitz alors il est évident que
aussi bien pour Nicolas Sarkozi que pour
seolen royale le report des voix sera
déterminant que ce soit celui des des
voix du Front national ou ou des voix de
l'UDF François Gouard on ne sait pas
encore euh vers qui va pencher le cœur
de François Baayou pour ce 2e tour il
n'a pas donné de consignes de vote
est-ce que vous avez une idée euh de du
candidat qui aura à sa faveur non parce
que c'est vrai que sa démarche est très
originale par rapport à ce qu'on a
entendu jusqu'à présent vous savez dans
dans dans ce scrutin dans ce premier
tour il y a deux phénomènes assez
étonnants il y a d'abord euh l'UMP et le
Parti socialiste leurs candidats qui ont
d'une certaine manière siphonné leurs
extrêmes très net dans les
chiffres un réflexe après l'élection de
2002 pour la gauche des thèmes de
campagne choisi par le candidat de l'UMP
pour la droite et le deuxième phénomène
et qui est un phénomène massif c'est que
des électeurs de gauche et de droite qui
sont des modérés n'ont pas accepté cette
simplification et ont adressé un message
pour certains à la gauche pour d'autres
à la droite qu'il fallait entendre la
voix de la modération alors moi je suis
persuadé que pour les électeurs de GAE
frou l'extrême centre mais c'est c'est
un appel à la modernisation par rapport
aux autres partis socialiste européens
il est évident que le Parti socialiste
français a un retard considérable et je
crois qu'un certain nombre de gens qui
ont voté pour François baayrou sont
insatisfaits de la gauche française et
de la même façon il y a des électeurs de
droite modérés attachés un certain
nombre de principes qui ont considéré
qu'il y avait un certain nombre
d'éléments du discours de Nicolas
Sarkozi qui n'était pas satisfaisant
alors maintenant dans cette période
cruciale entre les deux tours je pense
que les uns et les autres attendent des
candidats des explications et et pour ma
part moi je n'ai jamais caché je suis un
homme de droite j'étais en désaccord
avec un point un certain nombre de
points avec Nicolas Sarkozi j'attends
des explications j'attends un discours
différent de celui du premier tour parce
que il y a au moins trois étape il y a
bien sûr le premier le premier tour
c'est important il y a le deuxème tour
et puis il y a ensuite l'action
gouvernement
alors Jean-Michel pardon de petites
secondes de petites secondes parce que
nous avons des images qui arrivent à
l'instant de la rue de Solferino du
siège du Parti socialiste des images de
de joie
évidemment de des militants extrêmement
satisfaits qui ont sorti les drapeaux
drapeau bleu blanc rouge mais pas mais
pas seulement il y a d'autres drapeaux
qui donc sont devant le siège du Parti
socialiste rue de Solferino des dizaines
et sans doute beaucoup plus des
peut-être des centaines de militants du
de segégolen Royal qui explosent de joie
Segolen Royal qui est donc qualifié ce
soir pour le second tour avec
25,9 % des voix voilà c'était des images
importantes à vous donner comme ça en
direct des images que que l'on découvre
ensemble on va se tourner vers françois
repsamen qui représente ici c'est goen
royal on entendait François Goulard à
l'instant qui qui attend un message de
la part des candidats on demandera tout
à l'heure à Jean-François Copé il y a
une semaine on a entendu Michel recard
et puis Bernard couchner puis même un
petit peu avant on avait entendu Daniel
conbandit lancer des appels qu'est-ce
que dit ce soir le Parti socialiste en
direction des électeurs de François
Baayou est-ce qu'on peut recomposer le
paysage politique différemment je je ne
crois pas qu'il faille aborder le
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle dans des relations entre
les partis politiques je pense que
l'élection présidentielle c'est aussi
notamment au deuxème tour une relation
qui secré entre une candidate je
l'espère cgolen royale et les Françaises
et les Français seégolen royale pte une
politique de changement autour de son
pacte présidentiel et c'est donc en
développant ces propositions pour un
état impartial pour des modifications
profondes de la vie institutionnelle
française pour la nécessité de d'avoir
un référendum européen qu'elle va
s'adresser aux Français et elle va
s'adresser aux Français pour leur dire
sa volonté de rassemblement cette
volonté d'avoir une autre politique
économique et sociale que celle qui est
menée depuis 5 ans et je voudrais dire
que c'est une nouvelle élection qui
commence ce soir et il faut en la
matière convaincre les Françaises et les
Français que tous ceux qui ont rejeté
d'une certaine manière la politique
menée depuis 5 ans ce soir c'est aussi
le constat que je fais vous êtes en
train de nous dire François rsen qu'il
n'y aura pas le moindre petit signe en
destination de François Baayou ou de son
électorat ça ne se passe pas par des
signes ça se passe par politique c'est
souvent des signes et des symboles et
bien le principal symbole c'est le pacte
présidentiel et les propositions qui
figurent aux françaises et aux Français
qui ont voté pour François Baayou au
premier tour et bien d'ipuiser je crois
cette volonté de changement que j'ai
senti ce soir à travers le vote pour
sgolen royale jean-rançois Coppé est-ce
que Nicolas Sarkozi peut se passer des
voix de François Baayou pour le deème
tour mais je crois surtout qu'il peut se
passer d'aucune voix la seule chose si
vous voulez c'est que je sais pas si
Monsieur Goulard et Monsieur monsieur
Baayou appelleront à voter pour la
gauche comme l'a fait monsieur
besancenau et l'extrême gauche il y a
une chose que je sais en revanche et
celle-là elle est claire le message de
Nicolas Sarkozi ce soir il est à
l'adresse de tous les Français pour
expliquer convaincre inlassablement
qu'on a besoin d'une France rassemblé et
surtout d'être évidemment en rupture et
en particulier avec en rupture avec un
projet socialiste monsieur monsieur Ren
qui a montré assez clairement les choses
ben sans doute bien sûr parce que le le
temps passe enfin aussi ça c'est sûr
avec le projet socialiste qui nous
expliquait pendant toute la campagne
vous alliez généraliser les 35 heur vous
alliez même renationaliser EDF c'est
dire que sur ces sujets il est
absolument grand temps qu'on en change
je je monsieur Kol a a revu à la hausse
les estimations du score de Nicolas
Sarkozy puisqu'on a dépassé le seuil des
30 % ce qui fait un vrai écart avec ces
Golen Royal je ne sais ce que fera
monsieur Baayou mais en tous les cas
naturellement tous les électeurs sont
les bienvenus au 2e tour a commencé
naturellement par ceux de l'UDF car je
veux rappeler mais monsieur
gouardal tous les électeurs bien sûr je
oui bien sûr mais je veux simplement
dire à Monsieur Baayou puisqueil
rappelait tout à l'heure qu'il était un
homme de droite que ces électeurs cette
famille c'est moi qui a dit c'est pas Ba
qui parlaitsieur g et que les uns et les
autres on a rappelé naturellement qu'on
appartient à une même famille celle qui
veut naturellement rassembler tous les
Français autour de valeurs clair le
travail le pouvoir d'achat mais aussi
l'identité qu'est-ce que c'est être
français aujourd'hui et demain
construire ensemble au-delà des
différences il est grand temps que l'on
passe ce CAP et le message de Nicolas
Sarkozi sur ce point était parfaitement
clair et d'ailleurs Rachid adati l'a
beaucoup dit durant cette campagne aussi
nous allons nous allons entendre Rachid
adati dans dans un instant j'aimerais
aller à
Miami on a des moyens à France 3 on va à
Miami par la
webcam nous allons avoir un internaute
puisque cette soirée nous l'avons aussi
réalisé grâce à nos amis internautes
puisque cette campagne électorale c'est
également faite sur sur le net Pierre De
Agostini vous êtes en direct avec nous
de de Miami comment avez-vous vécu cette
soirée électorale ben écoutez d'abord
nous tenons à remercier franrois pour
l'intérêt que Françis apporte aux
françaises et aux Français de l'étranger
nous sommes ici réunés un groupe d'une
trentaine de personnes dans un
restaurant français Coral de gubol c'est
évidemment nous vivons avec grand
intérêt les résultats du premier tour
qui sont importants pour la France et
surtout pour aussi pour la France de de
l'étranger que nous que nous
représentons il y avait de de l'ambiance
là là où vous êtes il y avait des
partisan de de Nicolas Sarkozi de sgolen
Royal oui oui mais je pense qu'il y
avait des partisans des deux parties
vous savez la France de l'étranger votre
votera sans doute plus pour Nicolas
Sarkozi ce sont les statistiques mais
mais toutes les toutes les tendances et
toutes les les les les les les courants
sont sont représentés et donc et donc et
donc nous sommes tous là réunis vous
entendez pas beaucoup de bruit parce
qu'on a eu quelques des difficultés
techniques donc on veut s'assurer euh
qu'il n'y aura pas de problème mais si
vous voulez entendre je peux demander
à la la à la foule ben allez-y allez-y
allez lâchez-vous am écoutons la foule
écoutons la foule en
Floride
pardon allez-y allez-yâ merci beaucoup
d'avoir joué le jeu en tout cas merci et
bonne fin de de journée du côté de de la
Floride rachidti je vous en prie audre
Frédéric nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
rachidti également monsieur ni j'ai
envie de vous dire vous avez perdu un
peu votre Paris on va interrompu par la
déclaration de François Baayou oui
pardonnez-moi une nouvelle fois Françis
Baou il y aura un débat ne vous
inquiétez pas priorité priorité au
direct puisquon on me dit dans
l'oreillette que François berou
s'apprête à faire sa sa déclaration
voilà il est arrivé au pupitre François
berou qui qui reste le 3è homme annoncé
comme le 3è homme il est le 3è homme ce
soir avec 18,5 % des suffrages je vous
propose d'écouter François berou
[Applaudissements]
j'ai j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour
vous
à partir de ce soir la politique
française a changé et elle ne sera plus
jamais elle ne sera plus jamais comme
avant malgré des manœuvres
innombrables malgré l'alliance objective
du Parti socialiste et de
l'UMP malgré des sondages manipulés je
veux rappeler que certains instituts
n'hésitez pas à avancer ces dernières
heures encore que l'extrême droite
allait être devant nous malgré cela
malgré ses forces considérables plus de
7 millions de Français se sont réunis
pour porter une magnifique idée du
[Applaudissements]
changement c'est
assez
après
c'est à ces millions de Français que je
pense ils ont fait une magnifique
campagne électorale ils ont formé une
force nouvelle la seule force nouvelle
de la politique française ils ont ouvert
un chemin d'espoir pour la France et ce
chemin d'espoir ne s'arrêtera
pas il y
a il y a enfin un Centre en France un
centre
un centre large un centre fort un centre
indépendant capable de parler et d'agir
au-delà des frontières d'autrefois cela
ces millions de Français ont compris que
la vieille guerre des deux camps ne
répondait plus au mal de la France et je
vous le dis le de la France est plus
grave qu'on ne le croit dans les deux
parties qui sont encore ce soir arrivé
en tête nous ne sortirons pas la France
de la situation qui fait souffrir tant
de femmes et tant d'hommes qui ont
besoin qu'on s'occupe deux et pas des
guerres de partis nous n'en sortirons
pas sans un changement profond cela ces
millions de citoyens ont voulu qu'on ne
raconte pas d'histoire au pays que l'on
ne fasse pas de fausses promesses qu'on
les regarde comme des citoyens
c'est-à-dire comme des responsables
cette espérance que nous avons fait
naître j'en ai la charge je ne
l'abandonnerai pas ni une
[Musique]
minute ni je ne l'abandonnerai pas ni
une minute ni une seconde
pendant les jours les semaines et les
mois qui viennent j'aime cette espérance
je mettrai toutes mes forces à rénover
la politique française j'ai voulu la
rénover hier je la rénoverai demain je
[Musique]
n'abandonnerai je n'abandonnerai aucune
de ces convictions je ne reviendrai pas
en arrière je récuse et je récuserai
toujours l'idée qu'il n'y ait en France
que deux idées de l'avenir l'avenir de
la France exige au contraire qu'on fasse
vivre ensemble les valeurs des uns et
des autres l'avenir de la France exige
une démocratie profondément nouvelle
honnête avec des règles et des principes
si souvent bafoués depuis longtemps
toutes les décisions que je serais amené
à prendre dans les jours qui viennent
toutes les positions que nous adopt on
seront inspirés par cette seule
conviction la nouvelle politique est en
train de naître cette espérance est
grande et juste et personne vraiment
personne ne l'arrêtera je vous
remercie voilà c'était François Bou en
direct sur François François berou qui
n'appelle à voter pour personne qui
laisse la porte ouverte donc le le débat
va être passionnant rachidti vous êtes
déçu par ce manque de prise de position
de François baayerou non
mais Nicolas Sarkozi est ouvert la main
est tendue les électeurs de
l'UDF qui est quand même qui qui sont
qui ont été élus sur des valeurs de
droite Nicolas Sarkozi rassemblera tous
les Français il essaiera de rassembler
tous les Français il parlera à tous les
Français donc ça n'est pas une
déception François baayrou a fait une
campagne tout à fait respectable avec un
score honorable donc il s'adresse à tout
à tous les Français Nicolas sarzi peut
l'emporter sans un appel clair de
Françis Baayou a voté pour lui ça c'est
la c'est de la décision de François
Baayou si mais les électeurs ne personne
n'est propriétaire des Français et donc
des électeurs les Français comme ils
l'ont prouvé ce soir on se sont
mobilisés massivement c'est vraiment une
victoire de la démocratie ils se
mobiliseront de je pense de la même
manière pour le deuxème tour mais
Nicolas Sarkozi parlera à tous les
Français Gou Mo il y a quelque chose que
je comprends pas tout à l'heure parce
que Jean-François Copé nous a fait aussi
des grands élans sur Nicolas Sarkozi
rassembleur Nicolas Sarkozi candidat de
la rupture mais d'abord je vois pas
comment il peut rassembler les Français
alors qu'il a passé son temps à opposer
les uns aux autres à stigmatiser des
catégories de la population à traiter
les jeunes de quartiers populaires de
racaille à par exemple stigmatiser les
jeunes qui se suicident ou alors ceux
qui sont délinquants en expliquant que
c'était génétique donc je ne vois pas
comment il peut rassembler les Français
je pense même que c'est un candidat qui
peut considérablement cliver et
accroître les peurs dans notre pays
quant à la rupture c'est quasiment une
vanne comment Nicolas Sarkozy qui
participe au gouvernement depuis 5 ans
pourrait-il représenter une rupture
Nicolas Sarkozi est un homme qui a un
bilan il a un bilan je pense par exemple
à no qui est l'une des communes les plus
riches de France si ce n'est la commune
la plus riche de France et où pour ne
prendre qu'un exemple il y a 2,7 % de
logements sociaux vous croyez qu'avec
Nicolas Sarkozi on va avoir plus de
protection sociale davantage de
servicees public davantage de haements
sociaux on peut s'asseoir dessus je
ex à droitee je termine sur une phre
vous me permettez Monsieur unee juste
pour dire que face à un projet de droite
ultralibéral et autoritaire il va
falloir que la gauche de gauche soit
également mobilisé dans cette campagne à
sa manière et fasse entendre sa voix je
propose notamment des meetings comm
nationalement a été clair làdus qu'il
souhaite un débat d'idée n'insultez pas
ne dites pas stigmatiser n'insultez pas
les plus de 11 millions de Français
pas mille on comis était de parler de
tout des sujets dont il parl qu' sont
qui préoccupent les Français vous pensez
pas que le suicide des jeunes ça
préoccupe les
Français cont pour
TER
avec votre
permission répu les franais à force de
diabolis% là il a 7 millions point de
vue rachidti j'imerais qu'on écoute
celui de François Gouard et Frédéric
nous n'a pas encore eu la possibilité
deexprimer d'un mot vous l'avez rappelé
personne ne peut être élu s'il n'y a pas
des électeurs qui ont voté pour François
baayerou qui se prononcent pour l'une ou
pour l'autre bon et moi ce que j'entends
alors c'est vrai que nous sommes à
quelques dizaines de minutes des
résultats mais ce que j'entends de la
part des représentants de Segolen royal
ou de la part des représentants de
Nicolas Sarkozi me montre que tout n'a
pas été compris il y a des Françaises et
des Français qui en ont un peu assez
qu'on oppose les uns aux autres qu'on
dise que tout est faux d'un côté que
tout est épouvantable de l'autre et que
ceux qui aspirent à une autre vision de
la politique on n'en veut pas choisissez
il y a rien d'autre et bien je crois
qu'il y a là une profonde erreur ça
n'est pas un hasard si un candidat qui
qui était donné à 5 % est arrivé à plus
de 18 % ça veut dire quelque chose et il
faut que les uns et les autres l'intègr
excusez-moi une élection présidentielle
c'est une une une élection uninominale à
deux tours c'est pas la proportionnel
donc au deuxème tour il faut bien
choisir il faut choisir mais il faut
aussi entendre les électeur Frédéric
news merci de nous avoir rejoint sur ce
plate euh est-ce que finalement vous
n'avez pas louper le coche rater votre
Paris qui était notamment de de de
recueillir plus de age que Dominique
voet là c'est encore serré on a pas
encore les résultats définitifs pour
l'instant nos estimations nous donne
Dominique voet oui pour l'instant nos
estimations nous donn Dominique voanet à
1,50 % des voix et votre liste Chasse
Pêche Nature et tradition à 1 % des voix
bon ça on va voir un petit peu après moi
ce que je voudrais dire d'abord c'est
qu'il il y a déjà deux réussites dans
dans cette campagne c'est que d'abord
tout le monde estimit que on avait
disparu et qu'on pourrait pas être
candidat on a réussi à obtenir les
parinages donc ça prière réussite deè
c'est qu'on a réussi à imposer quand
même le débat de la ruralité dans ce
débat public et politique dans dans
cette élection ce qui est pas
négligeable ça touche 15 millions de
Français quand même puisque tous les
autres candidats ont dû ont dû se
positionner ont dû parler sur sur ces
sujets là deuxième réussite bon
maintenant faut voir ce qu'il en
adviendra par la suite on a trop
l'habitude justement des des grandes
déclarations de campagne qui sont oublié
une fois l'élection passé alors
maintenant pour le reste moi ce que je
note c'est qu'effectivement moi comme
comme d'autres on est victime de de
cette énorme mobilisation mais on va pas
se plaindre non plus que les Français a
retrouvé le chemin des urnes au
contraire on peut que s'en féliciter
mais néanmoins les Français restent
traumatisés de d'avril d'avril 2002
c'est ça la grandeçon ce soir c'est que
je voudrais finir le là-dessus c'est que
malheureusement on s'est fait un peu
confisquer cette élection c'est le 3e
tour de 2002 aujourd'hui tout simplement
hein c'est que le on nécoute plus il y a
plus de France des différences on
nécoute plus les autres idées il faut
espérer maintenant que que les les deux
qui qui restent ici pour le deuxè tour
et donc celui ou celle qui sera
président euh sortira de l'autisme et
écoutera aussi et proposera en matière
de ruralité vous Frédéri quel consigne
de vote allezvous donner à vos amis
chassurs ce soir ce soir je n'en donne
pas moi j'attends de de voir ce que les
deux finalistes on ont à proposer dans
dans ces questionslà et c'est en
fonction de ça sur le con quand même ça
fait des semaines et des semaines il y a
deux projets qui qui s'affrontent c'est
assez clair vous savez oui enfin c'est
des projets qui s'affrontent sur
certaines notions et pas du tout sur la
ruralité la la ruralité concrètement
c'est pas ce qu'ils vont proposer
là-dessus donc moi je vais pas partir
les lesux demander ici dès ce soir à
dire je donne une consigne ou j'en donne
pas non j'attends de voir tout
simplement avec le recul et on verra si
on donne une consigne pardonnez-moi nous
allons faire un petit tour à Mel dans
les Deux Sèvres où la candidate
socialiste ne s'est toujours pas exprimé
mais où ces militants rassemblé dans
dans cette commune sont sont nombreux
ils ils attendent ils attendent la la
candidate d'ailleurs ils ne regardent
pas la bonne chaîne il faut qu'il
regarde France 3 euh il va falloir leur
dire donc les les militants et les les
soutiens de segégolen royale attendent
la déclaration de leur candidateattente
alors dans l'attente de la déclaration
de cégolen royale je voudrais donner la
parole à Bruno golnich on a parlé du
report éventuel de voix de François
baayrou Jean-Marie Le Pen attendra le
1er mai pour donner des consignes de
vote tout de même est-ce que vous pensez
que l'un des deux candidats peut se
passer des voix du Front national non je
crois que le le Front National est en
position d'arbitre c'est c'est certain
il n'est pas le seul d'ailleurs tout à
fait dans cette dans cette échéance mais
euh le vrai problème c'est de savoir
jusqu'où ira la persistance de
l'exclusion de millions de Français
parce qu'ils sont quand même là ces
millions de Français et ils n'ont pas un
seul député un seul sénateur pour
exprimer à la fois leurs souffrances et
leurs espérances dans ce que l'on ose
encore appeler la représentation
nationale c'est-à-dire le Parlement le
le Sénat l'Assemblée nationale je pense
que il faut qu'il mène de façon ardente
euh après la la détion engagement
pour pour la proportionnelle soit pour
l'élection législative et en ce qui
concerne la proportionnelle nous ne
demandons pas les miettes nous demandons
que l'on rende la parole au peuple et je
pense que ce peuple il ne va pas tarder
à se rendre compte aussi que l'espèce de
zapping qu'on lui propose toujours entre
les deux mêmes formations politiques qui
ne change pas fondamentalement les
cadres la situation internationale notre
asservissement à l'Europe par ex exemple
l'ouverture des frontières incontrôlées
ces deux candidats ne sont pas en mesure
de répondre
au merci Monsieur golnich pardonnez-moi
nous allons écouter la la réaction
d'Arlette laguillet qui ce soir qui ce
soir réalise 1,4 % c sa dernière
campagne présidentielle la candidate de
lut ouvrière je vous propose d'écouter
la déclaration d'Arlette
laguyer je souhaite de tout cœur que
Sarkozy soit battu car son arrogance ne
mérite que cela et son programme ne vise
qu'à combler de cadeaux le patronat et
en particulier le patronat le plus
puissant les mesures qu'il a annoncé
sont dans la continuation de ces 5 ans
du pire gouvernement que nous ayons eu
depuis longtemps c'est-à-dire pressurer
les pauvres pour donner plus et plus à
ceux qui s'enrichissent au dépend de la
population
je voterai donc pour sgolen royale et
j'appelle tous les électeurs à en faire
autant mais si je fais ce choix je le
fais uniquement par solidarité avec tous
ceux qui dans les classes populaires
déclarent préféré tout sauf Sarkozy
voilà Arlette laguyet qui appelle donc
très officiellement à vootter ségolen
Royal c'est une nouveauté hein puisque
vous vous en souvenez en 2002 harlette
lagaguyet n'avait pas appelé à voter
Jacques Chirac face à Jean-Marie Le Pen
nous allons voir ce qui se passe du côté
de de Mel dans les Deux Sèvres le le
fief électoral de segégolen royale on
attend toujours la déclaration de la
candidate ça ne serait tardé me
dit-on
surtin on a vu tout à l'heure Olivier
besancenau à l'instant Arlette lagaguyer
est-ce que ce soir comp tenu des
résultats et du faible score du Parti
communiste on va vers une recomposition
de la gauche de la gauche euh c'est fort
probable je pense qu'on a été dans un
petit peu loin dans la décomposition et
que cette présidentielle a été plutôt
l'occasion d'une concurrence entre
toutes les sensibilités de la gauche de
gauche de la gauche antilibérale et moi
je pense que le fait que on soit comme
ça autour de petit score qu'on nit pas
réussi à créer la surprise que
finalement il y a eu quatre grands
candidats entre guillemets et dans ces
quatre g candidats il y avait trois de
droite et un de gauche je pense que si
nous avions été rassemblés nous aurions
pu créer cette surprise alors maintenant
moi j'ai envie de regarder devant je
pense qu'il faut essayer d'éviter
l'écueil des rancœurs de se compter les
uns les
aut refonder la gauche de la gauche ça
veut dire
d'abordour qui a autour du facteur
besanenau je pense que je pense
qu'Olivier besancenau a toute sa place
il a fait une campagne extrêmement
claire brillante et il a l'atout du
renouvellement générationnel ce qui
n'est pas rien pour autant le problème
c'est quel projet comment on articule à
la fois la lutte contre le libéralisme
économique mais aussi le féminisme
l'écologie une manière de penser la
démocratie de manière radicale et
comment on arrive à avoir une stratégie
claire et une forme organisationnelle
qui soit neuve donc c'est plein d'enjeux
qui sont devant nous moi je suis
extrêmement déterminé enthousiaste pour
refonder et j'espère que dans les mois
qui vont suivreent là il y a 15 jours
pour battre Nicolas Sarkozi mais que par
la suite nous allons réussir à refonder
une gauche bien à gauche il faut
refonder la gauche de la gauche écoutez
moi je suis fonder une gauche bien à
gauche al B il faut refonder la gauche
la gauche écoutez moi je suis pour
d'abord je suis pas pour trier dans la
gauche la gauche elle est plus large que
ce qu'on appelle la petite gauche je
considère que un rassemblement de petit
c'est un petit rassemblement et que le
Parti communiste a son existence certes
il a subi des périodes difficiles il est
affaibli et d'ailleurs il est plus
qu'affaibli on a le sentiment qu'il est
justement justement est-ce que ça va
mieux pour les Françaises et les
français pour le monde du travail depuis
que le Parti communiste est affaibli
c'est une bonne question question à se
poser je me souviens que dans le passé
ilvon Chotard disait on fait pas la même
politique en France avec un parti
communiste à 20 % ou à 10 % à l'époque
sous-entendu c'est plus facile pour les
banquiers c'est plus facile de réaliser
l'exploitation qu'on connaît dans les
entreprises par exemple donc la question
de l'existence du Parti communiste pour
moi elle est claire le Parti communiste
a un avenir en tant qu'organisation
évidemment il faut qu'il se positionne
clairement ensuite il est pour le
rassemblement pas derrière lui il est
pour aider au rassemblement le plus
large comme on va le faire pour le deuxè
tour des présidentiels le rassemblement
le plus large pour lutter contre cette
domination de l'argent qui fait tant de
victimes où on voit un chômage lancinant
où on voit 7 millions de personnes dans
le pays qui vivent en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté où on voit le capital
financier s'accumuler sans cesse au
détriment de l'intérêt national par
exemple donc il y a besoin d'une force
et je ne pense pas que ce soit avec un
mouvement disons fleur bleue même fleur
rouge qu'on réglera le problème parce
par qu' en face il y a le CAC 40 en face
il y a la Commission de Bruxelles en
face il a il y a le FMI en face il y a
des institutions donc il faut moi je P
le Parti communiste reste enfermé
dans dans la place du très ouvert et
très rassemblé avec ses militants avec
ses élus et il est prêt à agir avec tout
le monde moi c'est comme ça conçit
l'avenir du Parti communiste rachidti
alors je vous avertis qu'on risque
d'être interrompu par la déclaration
degolen deéolen royale ouielti vous
allez pouvoir vous exprimer Rachid adati
on a beaucoup dit que Nicolas Sarkozi
avait réussi à imposer ses propres
thèmes de campagne euh pour cette
campagne du premier tour quels sont les
thèmes qu'il essaiera d'imposer pour
celui du second tour mis à part le rêve
français qu' le B le r français c'est
que que chacun puisse trouver sa place
qu'il soit par le travail par en
libérant les énergies mais aussi pour
les pour les plus pauvres pour les plus
fragiles de les protéger et c'est vrai
que pendant longtemps la gauche a
diabolisé les électeurs par exemple du
Front national en mais simplement
c'était en méprisant leur exaspération
et leur désespérance Nicolas Sarkozi a
trava a remis le travail au centre du
projet c'est je crois l' le politique
est le candidat qui est le plus allé
dans les usines quand il sauve Alstom il
s'engage auprès des ouvriers on n'a pas
vu d'autres personnes auprès de ses
ouvriers qu'est-ce que lui disaient ces
ouvriers disaient il y a trop de tout
monsieur Sarkozi mais pas assez dans la
gamelle aujourd'hui effectivement il y a
trop de tout il s'en est préoccupé il y
est allé oui il s'en préoccupé non non
mais pour terminer il s'en est préoccupé
le travail personne s'en est
préoccupéavurandat le candidat des
ouvriersou le travail le mérite les
valeurs pardon monsieur bet 90 % des
entreprises qui créent de l'emploi ce
sont des PME le grand patronat ça ne
veut rien dire neprz pas les Français
qui travaillent qui créent leurs
entreprises qui tous les jours les
artisans qui en bave tous les jours oui
justement par les 35 he ils sont bloqués
par les un cœur le travail n'a pas
valorisé celui qui travaille celui qui
travaille gagne autant que celui qui est
assé just
justement de mettre la fraternité dans
ce pays de remettre une France
fraternelle il a tout dit il dit tout
avant il a posé toutes les questions il
n'a pas peur il n'y a pas de question
tabou pas de sujet tabou il faut une
France plus fraternelle qui donne les
moyens à sa jeunesse de réaliser leur
rêve pas par la cistana en les
autonomisant et les responsabilisant
alors François on a eu l'impression
pendant toute la campagne et ça continue
un peu ce soir qu'on est en plein
marketing politique on appelle ça en
marketing la triangulation c'està dire
qu'on on on prend les les arguments de
l'adversaire he et dans l'intervention
de Nicolas Sarkozi on a bien compris
qu'il allait vous prendre tous les
arguments les arguments de la gauche oui
il a déjà il a déjà essayé de de le
faire allant de de Barès à à à jores
mais pour récupérer l'électorat
de l'extrême droite pour récupérer l'me
l'électorat de l'extrême droite Nicolas
SAR a développé des thèmes qui sont à
l'opposé du rassemblement nécessaire à
notre pays et vous savez très bien que
le mélange entre le thème de
l'immigration et celui de l'identité
nationale est un thème qui a heurté un
certain nombre de Françaises et de
Français qui qui sont aujourd'hui
persuadés que l'identité nationale c'est
une chose et qu'il n pas de mélange à
faire avec l'immigration et que notre
pays n'est pas menacé par le
l'immigration mais par le mélange des de
thèmes et donc je voudrais je voudrais
dire ici que le candidat le candidat du
du grand patronat c'est Nicolas Sarkozy
c'est c'est la Gard c'est c'est des
choses qu'on doit pas dire il paraît sur
les plateaux de moi je dire le candidat
du grand patron ce soir il ne peut pas
il ne peut pas s'exonérer il ne peut pas
s'exonérer de sa responsabilité du bilan
et ce que je constate ce soir c'est
qu'il y a certes un score tout à fait
estimable pour Nicolas Sarkozi mais
qu'il y a une volonté de changement
d'une grande majorité de Français qui en
a assez de cette politique qui met le
chômage la précarisation et les
injustices social en avant et c'est la
poursuite de cette politique que va nous
proposer Nicolas Sarkozi derrière les
mots qu'il avance et donc ce que nous
voulons nous au contraire c'est apporter
avec ces golenes Royal un véritable
rassemblement pour une France unie qui
porte les valeurs de progrès la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité et la laïcité
nous ne les déclinons pas de la même
manière madame et je pourrais vous le
prouver dans cette campagne
j'esè il y a là une opposition
fondamentale entre deux projets et ce
seront les Français qui
tranchum oui nous dans cette campagne
avec Philippe dev on on a mené une
campagne de vérité on fait pas la
politique pour parader au café du
commerce comme on le voit ici entre
l'UMP le parti socialiste c'estg Royal
le chômage de masse et Nicolas Sarkozi
qui dit un certain nombre de choses
juste mais qui est vrai sur l'Europe de
Bruxelles sur la politique familiale lui
qui propose un mariage homosexuel bis
sur le communautarisme et la place de
l'islam dit des choses qui nous
dérangent avec Philippe devier nous
souhaitons incarner pour les années qui
viennent une droite décomplexée sans
tabout de conviction et cette droite
décomplexé nous la porterons aux
élections législatives pour la première
fois dans l'histoire du mouvement nous
présenterons 577 être candidat dans
toutes les circonscriptions avec un
objectif c'est d'obtenir un groupe
parlementaire capable de peser et de
dire non à une droite qui cède par trop
à la gauche à la rue non à la gauche
archaïque bien sûr mais de faire
attention à cette droite qui comme
Chirac en 95 je me souvis en 95 on nous
disait Shirak c'est le mieux placé pour
tourner la page des années mitéran 12 12
ans après on a vu c'était 12 années de
présidence inutile et bien pour éviter
que Nicolas Sarkozi redevienne à Jacques
Chirac et bien Philippe de Villier sera
présent aux élections législatives pour
qu'on fasse vous si j'ai bien compris
votre objectif c'est de récupérer
l'héritage éventuel laissé par
Jean-Marie Le Pen non je me passe pas
là-dessus je répète je fais pas du café
du commerce pas de bataille de poelochon
c'est les idées qui mènent le monde mais
il est vrai que Jean-Marie Le Pen 2007
c'est une ligne d'arrivée au contraire
de Philippe dev Villier pour qui c'est
une ligne de départ d'une grande
aventure l'aventure du Mouvement pour la
France qui je le rappelle est le 6e
parti politique ce soir devant le Parti
communiste devant les Verts malgré des
moyens financiers dérisoir nous avons
fait une campagne de smicar par rapport
aux autres et puis et bien dans dans
dans un mois le 10 et 17 juin nous
aurons des candidats partout pour porter
la flamme et le drapeau tricolore la 6e
partie qui je le rappelle recueille pour
le moment selon nos estimations 2,30 2,3
% du suffrage ça reste très peu ça reste
très marginal dans un contexte difficile
de matraquage de sondage truqués 0,5 %
le dernier sondage vendredi dernier pour
empêcher là encore les électeurs de
voter Philippe Devillier nous atteignons
1 million de suffragees c'est pour nous
je le disais à la fois un sentiment de
fierté et un sentiment d'espoir de
fierté d'avoir dit la vérité dans cette
campagne sur les trois grandes erreurs
de notre temps le mondialisme et les
délocalisations le socialisme et le
laxisme éité de M 68 et le
communautarisme islamique en particulier
et d'espoir parce que nous créons ce
soir un grand parti politique le
Mouvement pour la France qui va peser
dans les années qui viennent et tout
particulièrement le 10 juin prochain
merci Guillaume P nous allons retrouver
l'ambiance du côté de de Mel dans les
Deux Sèvres où cgolen Royal devrai
arriver dans les instants qui viennent
en tout cas ces supporters l'attendent
avec maintenant beaucoup d'impatience
François a déjà parlé Jean-Marie Le Pen
aussi Nicolas Sarkozy également on
attendait la déclaration de la candidate
du Parti socialiste qui ce soir je vous
le rappelle arrive en 2e position avec
26,3% des voix c'est Golen royale en
direct sur France 3 je vous laisse
entendre la déclaration de la candidate
socialiste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pr
Pr em
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
perememem
française français mes chers
compatriotes à vous qui m'avez apporté
si nombreux vos suffrage
aujourd'hui je vous exprime ma joie et
ma profonde
gratitude un élan civique
s'élevé la très forte participation que
j'avais appelé de mes vœux et
là je mesure la responsabilité éminente
et qui
m'honore que vous me confiez ce
soir je n'en tire aucune gloire
personnelle vous me donnez une
responsabilité
majeure celle de porter le combat du CH
pour que la France se
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
relève ance se
relève qu'elle retrouve son
optimisme et qu'elle fasse le choix de
l'audace et de la
sérénité une nouvelle campagne
s'ouvre dans 15
jours la France va choisir son destin et
son
visage je lance un appel à toutes C et
ceux qui veulent que la France fasse
triompher la République du
respect parce que nous savons qu'il n'y
a pas de liberté sans
justice qu'il n'y a pas d'efficacité
économique sans progrès
social nous aurons le 6 mai prochain un
choix clair
entre deux voies très
différentes et je tends la main à toutes
celles et ceux qui pensent comme
moi qu'il est non seulement possible
mais urgent de quitter un système qui ne
marche
[Applaudissements]
plus mes chers
compatriotes je vous invite
a inventé une France neuve à la fois
protectrice et
dynamique une France à la fois
fraternelle et
conquérante et qui permet à chacun de
construire et de réussir sa
vie j'appelle ce soir au rassemblement
de toutes celles et ceux qui se
reconnaissent dans les valeurs du pacte
présidentiel et qui pense que l'on peut
réformer la France sans la
brutaliser qui veulent faire triomfit
toujours les valeurs humaines sur les
valeurs boursières qui veulent mettre
fin aux insécurité et aux précarités qui
se sont douloureusement creusé au cours
de ces dernières
années qui veulent faire reculer toutes
les formes de violence grâce à un ordre
juste et à de nouvelles sécurités
durbl je
continue à faire le Paris de
l'intelligence des Français et je refuse
de cultiver les
peurs il s'agit de mettre la priorité
sur
l'éducation de consolider les familles
d'épauler les plus
fragile et notamment nos anciens et les
personnes en situation de
handicap dont les conditions de vie se
sont gravement détériorées au cours de
ces C dernières
années j'entends
instaurer des règles justes dans la
mondialisation maintenir en France nos
centres de décision et notre tissu
Industri
refuser la régression sociale
qu'entraînerait l'abandon à un
libéralisme
effrainé nous ferons de l'emploi tous
ensemble notre combat
principal et nous le gagnerons avec des
entreprises performantes et conquérantes
qui respectent les salariés grâce à une
démocratie sociale
rénovée
je comprends la
déception de toutes celles et ceux dont
le ou la candidate n'est pas au second
tour mais je voudrais leur dire
ceci je serai la présidente garante d'un
état
impartial car vous le
savez je suis une femme libre comme vous
êtes un peuple libre
je ne suis l'otage d'aucun
clan d'aucun groupe de
pression d'aucune puissance
financière nous sommes nombreux et
nombreuses
aujourd'hui au-delà de notre vote du
premier tour à ne pas vouloir d'une
France dominer par la loi du plus fort
ou du plus brutal et verrouillé par les
puissances de l'argent où tous les
pouvoirs sont concentrés entre peu de
mains toujours les
mêmes avec
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi avec moi je vous propose de choisir
une démocratie où l'on respire librement
avec un parlement qui délibère et
contrôle un gouvernement qui a des
résultats et qui rend des
comptes un état sans
gaspillage une justice
indépendante des médias pluralistes et
des libertés publiques
[Musique]
garantie
ou je veux une
république refondée et non
garotée un état exerçant une autorité
juste et
ferme des régions
dynamiques des services public modernisé
et
performant avec des citoyens libres
éduqué par notre école conscient de leur
droit comme de leur
devoirs si vous me confier la
charge de présidente de la
République j'aurais à cœur de défendre
les intérêts de la
France en Europe et dans le
monde le patriotisme
républicain trouvera tout son sens dans
la construction d'une Europe socialement
et économiquement redressée et capable
de peser dans un monde
multipolaire les Français seront appelés
à se prononcer par
référendum sur le nouveau traité
européen celui-ci ne se fera pas à leur
[Applaudissements]
insu
cette Europe sera au service de la paix
elle uvrera au dialogue des
cultures au codéveloppement avec les
pays du Sud et à la préservation des
équilibres de la vie sur la
planète avec vous je vais rendre à la
France la fierté de son histoire qui
renoue avec ses valeurs
universelles car quand la France
rencontre une grande idée elles font
ensemble le tour du
monde je veux une France qui renoue avec
l'idéal de la République des
lumières les droits de l'homme et de la
femme et de la citoyenneté qui ont fait
sa force et sa
beauté venez hommes et femmes de France
de tous âges de tout milieu de tout
territoire et de toutes
origines venez forces vives de notre
belle nation
venez serrons-nous les coudes
ensemble nous allons rendre le sourire à
notre pays
ensemble nous allons conjurer
les mauvais démons de la déprime et du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
déclinésésentésidentésentés
rassemblons-nous ce sont nos
idées notre
idéal qui vont gagner car elles sont au
service de la France et des Français de
la paix civile et de l'harmonie sociale
j'appelle toutes les énergies et
l'Espérance à se mettre en mouvement
pour une France
victorieuse une France
présidente fière
d'elle-même pour que les Français
s'aiment en
elle notre victoire est possible car
l'audace et la générosité sont là c'est
une question de volonté et de cohérence
je les
ai j'ai besoin de vous parce que la
France a besoin de VOUS vive la
République vive la France
voilà c'était c'est Golen royal en
direct donc de mail dans les Deux Sèvres
un discours qui s'est fait attendre
parce que le discours a été sans doute
long à écrire c'est un long discours un
véritable discours programme pour lancer
la campagne de l'entre de tout en
quelque sorte Jean-Michel un très beau
discours il y avait d'ailleurs une sorte
de mimétisme entre la déclaration de
Nicolas Sarkozi en ce qui concerne la
longueur en tout casin et la profond ur
et mais surtout moi ce qui m'a frappé en
regardant l'intervention de la candidate
socialiste c'est espèce de sérénité de
solanité on assistait presque en direct
sur nos écrans de télévision à la
métamorphose de ségolen royale qui
jusqu'à présent n'était que la candidate
du Parti socialiste au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle et Dieu sait
si même à l'intérieur du camp socialiste
elle ne faisait pas l'unanimité il y
avait des doutes chez les militants
socialistes est-ce qu'elle arriver à
franchir le premier tour et là on a le
sentiment tout d'un coup que le fait
d'être qualifié pour ce second tour
alors que Jospin lonal Jospin avait été
éliminé en 2002 elle prend une autre
stature et un autre statut celui de la
candidate du Parti socialiste pour le 2è
tour et après la réponse sera évidemment
a 6 mai merci Jean-Michel nous aurons
évidemment le tout le temps de de
revenir sur cette déclaration sur celle
de Nicolas Sarkozi sur les enjeux du du
second tour dans la 2uxème partie de
soirée mais R Carol j'aimerais que vous
nous disiez un mot parce que vous êtes
en train de de concocter avec CSA et
Cisco un sondage exclusif pour nous de
que vous nous délivrerz tout à l'heure
oui on sait bien que lorsque on passe au
second tour les choses changent pour les
gens ils se font un comportement
électoral une intention de vote de
second tour un petit peu différente de
celle qu'il nous disait avant de savoir
quels étaient les résultats alors nous
avons donc décidé avec France I
d'interroger un échantillon national de
France par téléphone ce soir après
connaissance des résultats et donc nous
serons dans la deuxème partie de notre
soirée comment les Français nous ont
répondu à la fois comment ils prennent
les choses comment ils analysent le
climat politique et queles sont leurs
nouvelles intention de vote Royal
Sarkozi pour ce second tour ça veut dire
que vous allez nous donner le nom du
futur président de la République tout à
l'heure ça veut dire qu'on va parler
comme les sondeur on va vous dire ce que
serait le résultat si l'élection avait
lieu dimanche prochain il y a de
semaines merci mer Roland Kol ben on
attend ça avec impatience avec audre
nous allons vous rappeler avant de se
quitter les résultats de la soirée
résultats des estimations même si elles
s'affine ce sont encore des estimations
fournies par nos partenaires CSA Cisco
France Info le Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France Nicolas Sarkozi qui arrive donc
en tête avec 30,6 % des voies suivies de
seggolen Royal 25,9 François berou pour
l'UDF 18,5 Jean-Marie Le Pen 10,8 et
selon ses estimations olivier besancenau
est en 5e position avec 4,5 % des voix
Philippe Devillier 2,3 % Marie-George
Buffet 2 % et Dominique voanet 1,5 %. et
puis pour les autres candidats Arlette
laguillet recueille 1,4 % des suffrages
José Bovet 1,2 % Frédéric nous 1 % et
Gérard Chivardi 0,3 % il s'agit on le
rappelle d'estimation merci à tous merci
à nos invités je vous retrouve nous vous
trou avec plaisir juste après le film
car ce soir le président sur France 3
s'appelle Émile Beaufort alias jean-
Gabin c'est le président d'Henry
Verneuil tout de suite on se retrouve
juste après le film pour d'autres
analyses d'autres réactions d'autres
estimations et le sondage exclusif pour
France 3 à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
merci